Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks, and only make left turns where it's safe to do so.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，因为 Eglinton Crosstown 轻轨列车正在进行测试。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能在轨道上通过。请务必遵守所有交通信号。在轨道沿线请小心谨慎，仅在安全的情况下进行左转。
Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. Chiara. It means smart in Italian. Too bad your barista can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name. Your cafe name. Giulia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute.
保持警惕，提高意识，注意安全。Chiara。在意大利语中是“聪明”的意思。可惜你的咖啡师拼不对。所以你只能报个假名。你的咖啡馆名字。Giulia。但你用得越多，就越觉得像是在证人保护计划里。等等。
What kind of espresso drinks does Giulia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. Mama, look at me. Vroom, vroom.
Giulia 到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改点拿铁还来得及吗？但如果有一台 KitchenAid 的浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些顾虑了，因为你完全可以在家自己做。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。妈妈，看我。呜呜，呜呜。
I'm going really fast. I just got my license. Can I borrow the car, please, Mom? Kids go from 0 to 18 in no time. You'll be relieved they have 24-7 roadside assistance with intact insurance. Mom, can we go to Nana's house tomorrow? zero to 18 in no time. You'll be relieved they have 24-7 roadside assistance with Intact Insurance. Mom, can we go to Nana's house tomorrow? I want to go to Jack's place today.
我开得好快。我刚拿到驾照。妈妈，我可以借用一下车吗？孩子们从 0 岁长到 18 岁转眼之间。你会庆幸他们有 Intact Insurance 提供的 24/7 道路救援。妈妈，我们明天可以去奶奶家吗？从 0 岁长到 18 岁转眼之间。你会庆幸他们有 Intact Insurance 提供的 24/7 道路救援。妈妈，我们明天可以去奶奶家吗？我今天想去杰克家。
I'll just take the car. Don't wait up, okay? Kids go from zero to 18 in no time, don't they? At Intact Insurance, we insure your car so you can enjoy the ride. Visit intact.ca or talk to your broker. Conditions apply. Those long, uneven lines, standing as patiently as if they were stretched outside the Oval or Villa Park.
我就开那辆车去。别等我了，好吗？孩子们从 0 岁长到 18 岁转眼之间，不是吗？在 Intact Insurance，我们为您的爱车提供保险，让您尽享驾驶乐趣。请访问 intact.ca 或咨询您的保险经纪人。适用相关条款。那些长长、不平整的队伍，站得那么耐心，仿佛延伸到了椭圆球场（The Oval）或维拉公园球场（Villa Park）外。
The crowns of hats, the sun on moustached archaic faces, grinning as if it were all an August bank holiday lark. And the shut shops, the bleached established names on the sunblinds, the farthings and sovereigns, and dark clothed children at play called after kings and queens. The tin advertisements for cocoa and twist, and the pubs wide open all day and the countryside not caring the place names all hazed over with flowering grasses and fields shadowing doomsday lines under wheat's restless silence the differently dressed servants with tiny rooms in huge houses the dust behind limousines. Never such innocence, never before or since, has changed itself to past without a word, the men leaving the gardens tidy, the thousands of marriages lasting a little while longer, never such innocence again.
帽子的帽顶，阳光照在留着胡须的古老面孔上，咧着嘴笑，仿佛这只是八月银行假日的一次嬉闹。还有那些关门的商店，遮阳篷上褪色的老字号招牌，法新币和金币，以及玩耍的穿着深色衣服的孩子们，他们的名字取自国王和王后。那些印着可可和烟草的铁皮广告，整天敞开的酒馆，还有那不在乎世事的乡村，地名被开花的草丛笼罩，田野在小麦不安的寂静下投射出末日般的线条，穿着不同服装的仆人们在豪宅里住着狭小的房间，豪华轿车后的尘土。从未有过这样的纯真，从未在之前或之后，就这样无声无息地变成了过去，男人们把花园收拾得整整齐齐，成千上万的婚姻又维持了一小会儿，再也没有这样的纯真了。
That was Philip Larkin's great poem 1914 which he wrote in 1964 so the 50th anniversary of the outbreak of the first world war in 1914 and dominic he wrote the title of that poem 1914 in latin numerals roman numerals to convey the sense i guess of a kind of archaic tomb. Exactly. Raised over the ashes of a vanished world. Yeah, absolutely. The doomsday lines, the pubs that were open all day, the moustached archaic bases, and that line, never such innocence again. The idea that 1914 was this world historical dividing point
那是菲利普·拉金（Philip Larkin）的伟大诗作《1914》，写于 1964 年，也就是第一次世界大战爆发 50 周年之际。多米尼克，他用拉丁数字，也就是罗马数字写下了这首诗的标题“1914”，我想是为了传达一种古老墓碑的感觉。没错。在消失的世界的灰烬之上竖起。是的，绝对是这样。末日般的线条，整天开放的酒馆，留着胡须的古老面孔，还有那句“再也没有这样的纯真”。1914 年是世界历史分水岭的观点
between that world that he describes in their poem and the modern that it's the seismic shift in human civilization there's no mistaking the scale of the catastrophe that the first world war represents i mean it's 110 years since it broke out yeah but it is still a massive shadow totally over europe over the world over our sense of what modernity is isn't it but if you think about the two great conflicts of 2023 2024 when we're when we planned and are recording this series the russian war in ukraine and the conflicts in the middle east israel and gaza both of those can be traced back to their clash of empires and the destruction of empires in the First World War. So the destruction of czarism in Russia,
在那首诗所描述的世界与现代世界之间，这是人类文明的剧烈转变。第一次世界大战所代表的灾难规模是毋庸置疑的。我的意思是，距离它爆发已经 110 年了，但它仍然在欧洲、在全世界、在我们对现代性的认知上投下了巨大的阴影，不是吗？但如果你想想 2023 年到 2024 年这两场大冲突，也就是我们策划并录制这个系列节目的时候，俄罗斯在乌克兰的战争以及中东以色列和加沙的冲突，这两者都可以追溯到帝国之间的碰撞以及第一次世界大战中帝国的毁灭。所以，俄罗斯沙皇制度的毁灭，
the fall of the Kaiser's Germany, the Austro-Hungarian Empire, which falls back, and of course the Ottoman Empire. And Chris Clark starts his book, The Sleepwalkers, which we will be talking about a lot in the next few episodes. 65 million men were mobilized in the First World War. 20 million people died, military and civilian. 21 million people wounded. I mean, these aren't flesh wounds. These are people disabled, traumatized for life. It is the great cataclysm, isn't it? As one historian, Fritz Stern says, the calamity from which all other calamities sprang and yet dominic um that sense which is very powerfully articulated in larkin's
德意志帝国凯撒的倒台，奥匈帝国的崩溃，当然还有奥斯曼帝国。克里斯·克拉克（Chris Clark）在他的书《梦游者》（The Sleepwalkers）开头写道，我们将在接下来的几集里详细讨论这本书。第一次世界大战动员了 6500 万人。2000 万人死亡，包括军人和平民。2100 万人受伤。我的意思是，这些可不是皮肉伤。这些人终身残疾、遭受创伤。这是一场巨大的灾难，不是吗？正如历史学家弗里茨·斯特恩（Fritz Stern）所说，这是所有其他灾难的源头。然而，多米尼克，那种在拉金的
poem the sense that before the the war breaks out everything is stable everything is peaceful i mean we know that's not true because we did an episode on the coming of the Easter Rising in Ireland. And we know that Britain was on the point of civil war before the outbreak of the First World War. And in fact, Asquith, the prime minister, kind of greets the news of the outbreak of war with relief because he thinks that it will save the United Kingdom from a kind of terrible internal conflict. So let's just say where we are, because we are actually in Sarajevo. And this is going out a few days after the 110th anniversary of the shooting of Archduke Franz Ferdinand here.
诗中被有力表达出来的感觉，即战争爆发前一切都是稳定的，一切都是和平的。我的意思是，我们知道那不是真的，因为我们做过一期关于爱尔兰复活节起义前夕的节目。我们知道，在第一次世界大战爆发前，英国正处于内战的边缘。事实上，首相阿斯奎斯（Asquith）在得知战争爆发的消息时，甚至感到如释重负，因为他认为这能让联合王国免于一场可怕的内部冲突。所以，让我们说明一下我们现在在哪里，因为我们实际上是在萨拉热窝。这期节目是在弗朗茨·斐迪南大公在这里遇刺 110 周年纪念日几天后播出的。
I mean, a few meters from where we're actually sitting. Just down the end of this little street. And so that explains the hubbub of balkan noise in the background um there's a large man with a phone who's just the moment we started talking yeah began um shouting very volubly into his mobile behind us so i hope theo's managed to edit all that out i'm sure people are picking up tom is the uh sense of a crossroads between east and west you think yeah very much and gary and yes. Austro-Hungarian, Ottoman empires. Absolutely.
我的意思是，距离我们现在坐的地方只有几米远。就在这条小街的尽头。所以这就解释了背景中巴尔干半岛的喧嚣。有一个拿着手机的大个子，就在我们刚开始说话的时候，就开始在我们身后对着手机大声喊叫。所以我希望西奥（Theo）能把这些都剪掉。我相信大家都能听出来，汤姆，这里有一种东西方十字路口的感觉，你觉得呢？是的，非常强烈。加里（Gary）也是。奥匈帝国、奥斯曼帝国。绝对是。
Of course, it's the one thing everyone knows about the First World War is that it begins with this assassination. Yeah. But I was looking up the list of people just in the 20th century who got assassinated before 1914. Leaders, heads of state, prime ministers, and so on. So in 1900, the King of Italy was shot. 1901,
当然，关于第一次世界大战，每个人都知道的一件事就是它始于这次暗杀。是的。但我查了一下 20 世纪 1914 年之前被暗杀的人员名单。领导人、国家元首、首相等等。所以 1900 年，意大利国王被枪杀。1901 年，
president of the United States. 1903, and we'll be hearing about this, we'll be talking about this in due course, the king and queen of Serbia and its prime minister. 1907, the king of Bulgaria. 1908, the king of Portugal. 1911, the prime minister of Russia. 1912, the prime Minister of Spain, 1913, the King of Greece. So the question is, what was it about the shooting of the heir apparent of the Austro-Hungarian throne, Archduke Franz Ferdinand, that set this cataclysm in train? Was it merely contingent? Were there deeper processes at play? What's going on? I think it's a great question, Tom, and actually putting it in the context of those assassinations makes you think slightly differently about it. In other words, this is not a period of great stability and innocence
美国总统。1903 年，我们稍后会听到并讨论这件事，塞尔维亚国王和王后及其首相被杀。1907 年，保加利亚国王。1908 年，葡萄牙国王。1911 年，俄罗斯首相。1912 年，西班牙首相。1913 年，希腊国王。所以问题是，为什么奥匈帝国皇位继承人弗朗茨·斐迪南大公的枪杀案会引发这场灾难？这仅仅是偶然吗？背后是否有更深层的进程在起作用？到底发生了什么？我认为这是一个很好的问题，汤姆。事实上，把它放在那些暗杀事件的背景下看，会让你对它有不同的思考。换句话说，这并不是一个极其稳定和纯真的时期，
that is suddenly punctuated by this unforeseeable act of horrendous violence. This is one of many assassinations in the first decade and a half of the 20th century. So the question is, with the First World War, is it inevitable? Are there deep historical forces that are moving towards a conflagration? Or is there something about what happened here, a few hundred yards from where we're sitting, about that moment in Sarajevo and those two characters, Gavrilo Princip and the Archduke Franz Ferdinand, is that what makes the First World War happen? And also, what is it about the specifics of the various interests that the Archduke and the assassin represent?
突然被这起不可预见的恐怖暴力行为所打断。这是 20 世纪头 15 年里发生的众多暗杀事件之一。所以问题是，第一次世界大战是不可避免的吗？是否有深层的历史力量在推动战争的爆发？还是说，发生在我们现在坐的地方几百码外的那件事，关于萨拉热窝的那一刻，以及加夫里洛·普林西普（Gavrilo Princip）和弗朗茨·斐迪南大公这两个角色，才是导致第一次世界大战爆发的原因？还有，大公和刺客所代表的各种利益的具体细节是什么？
So what is it about the Balkans more generally that make them such a powder keg, Dominic? I think that's the phrase, isn't it? And it's a great honor for me to come here with you as an old Balkan hand. I've never been to the Balkans before, but with you, I have someone who, you know, you're as at home tramping the high mountains of Bosnia as you are at a cafe in Sarajevo. You speak the languages. You can blend into a crowd. And I'm going to be up front. I cannot speak a word of any of the languages that we're going to be using here.
那么，巴尔干半岛总体上有什么特点，使它成为一个火药桶呢，多米尼克？我想这就是那个短语，对吧？作为一名老巴尔干通，能和你一起来到这里，我感到非常荣幸。我以前从未去过巴尔干半岛，但有你在，就像在萨拉热窝的咖啡馆一样，你对波斯尼亚的高山了如指掌。你会说当地语言。你能融入人群。我要先说明一下，我们要在这里使用的任何语言，我一个字都不会说。
So I'm going to be reading off from our notes. I will be pronouncing them incorrectly. I can't wait. Looking forward to that. The master of tongues will have to correct me. But Tom, just to flesh out that story a little bit more, on the walk to this cafe, I was just telling you about when I was attacked by Bulgarian gypsies on the border between Turkey and Bulgaria. Happy days. Happy days.
所以我得照着笔记读。我会读错的。我等不及了。很期待。语言大师得纠正我。但汤姆，为了把那个故事讲得更丰满一点，在去这家咖啡馆的路上，我刚跟你讲过我被土耳其和保加利亚边境的保加利亚吉普赛人袭击的事。快乐的日子。快乐的日子。
And you got the police to arrest them, didn't you? That's the mark of a Balkan hat. Oh, my word. That's what we'll be cancelled for. Okay, so we are going to tell the stories of the assassin, the victim, and the murder. They are not incidental details. They're not footnotes. Some historians treat them as footnotes.
你还让警察逮捕了他们，对吧？这就是巴尔干通的标志。天哪。这就是我们要被取消资格的原因。好吧，我们要讲讲刺客、受害者和谋杀案的故事。它们不是无关紧要的细节。它们不是脚注。有些历史学家把它们当作脚注。
I think they're not. I think they really, really matter. And I think, therefore, we should start with the man who started the conflict. The man who fires the first shot at the First World War. It's not the Kaiser. It's not Tsar Nicholas II. It's not Sir Edward Grey. it is gavrilo princip he is the most consequential gunman in history so tom you and i went to just before we sat down we went to the end of this road and
我认为不是。我认为它们非常、非常重要。因此，我认为我们应该从那个开启冲突的人开始讲起。那个打响第一次世界大战第一枪的人。不是凯撒，不是尼古拉二世沙皇，不是爱德华·格雷爵士。是加夫里洛·普林西普。他是历史上最具影响力的枪手。所以汤姆，就在我们坐下之前，你和我去了这条路的尽头，
there is the latin bridge where franz ferdinand was shot And there's a little tiny museum, isn't there? And outside they have sort of blown up, pixelated photographs of the moment. And one of them is this man being dragged away by the police. And you see that photo reproduced in tons of history books. Gavrilo Princip being arrested. It's not Gavrilo Princip. That's the thing. Even the museum has the photo,
那里就是弗朗茨·斐迪南被枪杀的拉丁桥。那里有一个小小的博物馆，对吧？外面有一些放大的、像素化的照片，记录了那一刻。其中一张是一个人被警察拖走。你在很多历史书中都能看到那张照片。加夫里洛·普林西普被捕。那不是加夫里洛·普林西普。这就是问题所在。甚至博物馆里也有那张照片，
but it isn't Gavrilo Princip. It's a man called Ferdinand Baerer who was caught up in the confusion and the chaos. And that sort of sense of Princip as he's just a cipher, he's a nobody, he's so obscure that people misidentify him. Actually, what that misses is he's an extremely modern figure and actually really interesting. And yet there is an awful lot that isn't known about him. I mean, because he comes from a very humble background. So not many written materials about him.
但那不是加夫里洛·普林西普。那是一个叫费迪南德·贝尔（Ferdinand Baerer）的人，他被卷入了混乱之中。那种认为普林西普只是一个代号、一个无名小卒的感觉，他太默默无闻了，以至于人们认错了人。实际上，这种看法忽略了他是一个极其现代的人物，而且非常有趣。然而，关于他的了解确实非常少。因为他出身非常卑微。所以关于他的书面资料不多。
His involvement in the shadowy world of Serbian espionage. I mean, all the records have been destroyed if they were ever written in the first place. And he's a very, very shadowy figure. So both of us have read a brilliant book called The Trigger by Tim Butcher, who was a war correspondent here in Sarajevo during the civil wars, and then came back here and he kind of literally walked in Princeps' footsteps
他参与了塞尔维亚间谍活动的阴影世界。我的意思是，如果这些记录曾经被写下来，现在也都被销毁了。他是一个非常、非常神秘的人物。所以我们俩都读过蒂姆·布彻（Tim Butcher）写的一本精彩的书《扳机》（The Trigger），他在内战期间曾是萨拉热窝的战地记者，后来又回到这里，他几乎是沿着普林西普的足迹，
from the remote village where he was born here, then to Belgrade, and then back again. And yet what's amazing about that is actually, I mean, it's incredible how much he's dug up, but also how little he's dug up. So lots of what we know comes from the trial, but actually the trial documents were all destroyed during the war, I think, and only the pencil shorthand notes of the stenographers survived. After the war, and particularly after the Second World War, a Yugoslav author called Vladimir Dedia basically tried to collate all the stories about Princip. But I think it's fair to say a lot of those stories are probably invented. They're folk tales that were made up after people knew
从他出生的偏远村庄来到这里，然后去贝尔格莱德，最后又回来。然而令人惊奇的是，他挖掘出的东西非常多，但同时挖掘出的东西又非常少。所以我们所知道的很多东西都来自审判，但事实上，审判文件在战争期间都被销毁了，我想，只有速记员的铅笔速记稿幸存了下来。战后，特别是二战后，一位名叫弗拉基米尔·德迪耶（Vladimir Dedijer）的南斯拉夫作家试图整理所有关于普林西普的故事。但我认为可以公平地说，其中许多故事可能是编造的。它们是人们在知道
what his place in history was. So they said, oh, yeah, of course, I remember Gavrila Princip at high school. You know, I knew he would be an assassin, all that kind of stuff. And I think a lot of that is a bit dodgy. Well, we've already done a series, a massive series on a famous assassination, namely the JFK assassination. And it's evident, looking at the stories and the myths that have surrounded that, that this process of kind of almost obfuscation is inevitable when something seismic happens, and particularly when the assassin is a figure of some mystery. It's almost inevitable that people are going to try and fill in the gaps.
他在历史上的地位后编造的民间传说。所以他们说，哦，是的，我当然记得高中的加夫里洛·普林西普。你知道，我知道他会成为一名刺客，诸如此类。我认为其中很多都是不可靠的。好吧，我们已经做过一个关于著名暗杀事件的大型系列节目，即肯尼迪遇刺案。显而易见，看看围绕那件事的故事和神话，当发生地震级的大事时，这种几乎是混淆视听的过程是不可避免的，尤其是当刺客是一个神秘人物时。人们几乎不可避免地会试图填补空白。
But I thought just, it's quite striking reading some of the accounts that very, very distinguished historians have written about it. I mean, there are multiple versions. People get the details in an incredible tangle. Yeah, multiple versions and tons of mistakes, by the way. I mean, we were discussing all the different books and comparing them. They will give you completely, wildly different accounts of, I mean, you'll see the assassination happened on Franz Ferdinand's wedding anniversary. It didn't. Sophie was pregnant. She wasn't. All of these kinds of things. And particularly when you get to the conspiracy, who's in charge of the conspiracy, who's recruiting whom, it becomes such a kind of... Well, it's still very sensitive, isn't it?
但我认为，读一些杰出历史学家写的关于此事的记述，非常引人注目。我的意思是，有多个版本。人们把细节搞得一团糟。是的，多个版本，而且顺便说一句，错误百出。我的意思是，我们讨论了所有不同的书并进行了比较。它们会给你完全、截然不同的记述。我的意思是，你会看到暗杀发生在弗朗茨·斐迪南的结婚纪念日。其实并没有。索菲怀孕了。她其实没有。所有这些事情。特别是当你谈到阴谋时，谁负责阴谋，谁在招募谁，它变得如此……好吧，这仍然非常敏感，不是吗？
It is, of course. We are in a city that suffered a terrible siege at the hands of people who view Prince Sip as a great hero. And he remains a very, very kind of politically fraught figure. I mean, we're sitting underneath buildings, some of which have bullet holes in them. That's the extent of the shell damage. I mean, that's how live that's how, how live this history is. Shall I tell people where he was born though? Yeah. You were going in with a word that
当然是。我们所在的这座城市曾遭受过一场可怕的围困，围困者将普林西普视为伟大的英雄。他仍然是一个非常、非常具有政治争议的人物。我的意思是，我们坐在一些建筑物下面，其中一些上面还有弹孔。这就是炮火破坏的程度。我的意思是，这段历史是多么鲜活。不过，我可以告诉大家他出生在哪里吗？是的。你要用一个词，
I know is terrifying to you. So, so he was born in, uh, in July, 1894 in a place called, I think, Obljaj. That's how it, that's how it's called. It's called Obljaj and it was in Herzegovina. So Herzegovina is the Western part of bosnia herzegovina very mountainous very rural mostar is the most famous with its bridge city there with its famous bridge so he's born in 1894 we absolutely know that bosnia herzegovina had been they were legally part of the ottoman empire but they had been administered by the austro-hungarians so balkan since 1878 so basically as we will see they were semi-detached in the ottoman empire and the austrians had marched in to establish their
我知道这对你来说很可怕。所以，他出生于 1894 年 7 月，在一个叫奥布利亚伊（Obljaj）的地方。这就是它的名字。它叫奥布利亚伊，位于黑塞哥维那。所以黑塞哥维那是波斯尼亚和黑塞哥维那的西部，非常多山，非常乡村。莫斯塔尔（Mostar）以其桥梁城市和著名的桥梁而闻名。所以他出生于 1894 年，我们完全知道波斯尼亚和黑塞哥维那在法律上是奥斯曼帝国的一部分，但自 1878 年以来一直由奥匈帝国管理。所以基本上，正如我们将看到的，他们是奥斯曼帝国的半独立部分，奥地利人已经进入并建立了
own kind of colonial regime obliai is a tiny place it wasn't on many maps until recently it's on google maps you can see it but excitingly for me an englishman who who did visit it is Arthur Evans, who would go on to discover Palace of Minos at Knossos, which we might be doing a series on later in the year. So he wrote about it. Those who may be inclined to try Bosnia will meet with many hardships. They must be prepared to sleep out in the open air in the forest or on the mountain side. So Dominic, that must speak to you because you've done that as well, haven't you? Yeah, absolutely. But he then goes on to say, you know, that must speak to you, because you've done that as well, haven't you? Yeah, absolutely. But he then goes on to say, you know,
他们自己的殖民政权。奥布利亚伊是一个很小的地方，直到最近才出现在许多地图上。它在谷歌地图上可以看到，但让我这个访问过它的英国人感到兴奋的是，亚瑟·埃文斯（Arthur Evans）也去过那里，他后来发现了克诺索斯的米诺斯宫殿，我们今年晚些时候可能会做一个关于这个的系列节目。所以他写道：那些倾向于尝试波斯尼亚的人会遇到许多困难。他们必须准备好在森林里或山坡上的露天环境中睡觉。所以多米尼克，这一定能引起你的共鸣，因为你也做过同样的事，不是吗？是的，绝对是。但他接着说，你知道，
if you love antiquity, if you perceive the high historic interest which attaches to the southern Slavs, if you take pleasure in picturesque costumes and stupendous forest scenery, then you'll love a trip to Bosnia. And that captured, obviously, how many outsiders viewed this. It was seen as the backwater, romantic,
如果你热爱古代，如果你能感知到南斯拉夫人所具有的崇高历史意义，如果你喜欢如画的服装和壮丽的森林风光，那么你会喜欢波斯尼亚之旅。这显然捕捉到了局外人是如何看待这个地方的。它被视为落后、浪漫的地方，
a place of wolves in the forest, of peasants in exciting costumes, all of that kind of stuff. And that is, I mean, Obliai is a very, very poor, obscure, fly-blown kind of place in the 1890s when Princip is born. His family are Bosnian Serbs. They probably originally had come from Montenegro. So that means they are Orthodox. They're not Muslim or Catholic like many other people in Bosnia. They possibly had been settled, Tim Butcher suggests in his book, by the Ottomans, as is often the case with a lot of Bosnian Serbs,
森林里有狼，农民穿着令人兴奋的服装，诸如此类。在 1890 年代普林西普出生时，奥布利亚伊是一个非常、非常贫穷、默默无闻、苍蝇乱飞的地方。他的家人是波斯尼亚塞族人。他们可能最初来自黑山。这意味着他们是东正教徒。他们不像波斯尼亚的许多其他人那样是穆斯林或天主教徒。蒂姆·布彻在他的书中建议，他们可能是由奥斯曼人定居在那里的，正如许多波斯尼亚塞族人的情况一样，
been settled by the Ottomans to form a kind of buffer against the Catholic Habsburg Empire. Because the area where Obloy is is quite close to an area called the Krajina, the military frontier, which was the buffer zone between these different worlds, I suppose. It was seen as the buffer zone between Christian Europe and the world of the Islamic Ottoman Empire. The Princip family, they claim they took the name Princip, which means kind of princely,
由奥斯曼人定居在那里，以形成一种对抗天主教哈布斯堡帝国的缓冲。因为奥布利亚伊所在的地区非常接近一个叫克拉伊纳（Krajina）的地区，即军事边境，这是这些不同世界之间的缓冲地带。我认为它被视为基督教欧洲和伊斯兰奥斯曼帝国世界之间的缓冲地带。普林西普家族声称他们取名“普林西普”，意思是某种王子的，
because some old ancestor, people said, what an impressive man he was, tall and all this kind of thing. Actually, they're not a very princely family. They're very poor. They're basically serfs. Well, I mean, they kind of in a way literally are, aren't they? Because one of the details I thought was fascinating in Tim Butcher's book, he quotes the police report on Prince Sip in 1914 after the assassination and has a box that says, to whom does this surf belong? I was amazed by that.
因为一些老祖先，人们说，他是一个多么令人印象深刻的人，身材高大等等。实际上，他们并不是一个非常显赫的家族。他们非常贫穷。他们基本上是农奴。好吧，我的意思是，他们在某种程度上确实是，不是吗？因为蒂姆·布彻书中一个细节我觉得很迷人，他引用了 1914 年暗杀后关于普林西普的警察报告，上面有一个方框写着：这个农奴属于谁？我对此感到震惊。
Yeah. The Ottoman Empire in the Balkans was a very sleepy kind of place. You know, technological change, modernity didn't really come at all in the 19th century but then in 1875 there's a revolt across bosnia and herzegovina against the ottoman empire which the princip clan seemed to have joined so a kind of uh peasant revolt i guess against their muslim landowner their landlords and landowners who in Bosnia are the gentry, the upper classes. Exactly, exactly.
是的。奥斯曼帝国在巴尔干半岛是一个非常沉睡的地方。你知道，技术变革、现代性在 19 世纪根本没有到来，但 1875 年，波斯尼亚和黑塞哥维那爆发了针对奥斯曼帝国的起义，普林西普家族似乎也加入了，所以这是一种农民起义，我想，针对他们的穆斯林地主，而波斯尼亚的地主和土地所有者是绅士，是上层阶级。没错，没错。
That revolt lasts for three years. And at the end of it, as we already said, Bosnia-Herzegovina is effectively given to the Austrians. So the Austrians have marched in. It's nominally still part of the Ottoman Empire, but it's the Austrians who are given the right to run it. So can I ask you, that thing about the serfdom, which is a legacy of Ottoman rule,
那场起义持续了三年。正如我们已经说过的，最后，波斯尼亚和黑塞哥维那实际上被交给了奥地利人。所以奥地利人已经进驻了。它名义上仍然是奥斯曼帝国的一部分，但奥地利人获得了管理它的权利。所以我可以问你，关于农奴制的事情，这是奥斯曼统治的遗产，
is that still in place because the Austrians want to essentially leave things as they were? It's a kind of mark of sleeping dogs lie? Or is it because they're reformers, they want to get rid of it, but they just haven't got round to it? Or what's going on? I think the latter probably, Tom.
是因为奥地利人想基本上维持现状，所以它仍然存在吗？这是一种“多一事不如少一事”的标志吗？还是因为他们是改革者，他们想摆脱它，但只是还没来得及做？或者发生了什么？我想是后者，汤姆。
Well, a bit of both. So the Austrians had come in in 1878 they had been very boastful they'd said this would be a great laugh and actually they had to face an insurgency for about three or four months they had to send in loads of troops but once they're in situ the Austrians basically want to use this as a laboratory for a modernizing or they would call a civilizing project so the austrians already have many slav subjects we'll come to this in a subsequent episode in croatia and slovenia and slovakia and so on and they're anxious about slav nationalism particularly on their southern border and by taking over bosnia they can sort of make it a model colony i think that's their plan
好吧，两者都有。所以奥地利人在 1878 年进来时，他们非常自夸，他们说这会很有趣，实际上他们不得不面对大约三到四个月的叛乱，他们不得不派遣大量军队，但一旦他们到位，奥地利人基本上想把这里当作一个现代化实验室，或者他们称之为文明化项目。所以奥地利人已经有很多斯拉夫臣民，我们将在随后的剧集中讨论这一点，在克罗地亚、斯洛文尼亚、斯洛伐克等地，他们对斯拉夫民族主义感到焦虑，特别是在他们的南部边境，通过接管波斯尼亚，他们可以把它变成一个模范殖民地，我想这就是他们的计划。
yeah and you know what obviously empires get a very bad press these days but if you have to have an imperial overlord the austrians really are not that bad they set up all kinds of farms they have vineyards they have an agricultural training college they spend a lot of money on roads and railways now of course those railways are largely for their own benefits for their armies and so on but they encourage the timber industry they encourage mining in Sarajevo don't they introduce a tram system that then provides a model for Vienna they do indeed they do indeed Tom so when we went to the museum you know we saw that little list of achievements that they have in the museum the museum is very pro-austrian yeah it sort of says oh brilliant brickyards a lovely road with asphalt on it
是的，你知道，显然帝国在这些天得到了非常糟糕的评价，但如果你必须有一个帝国霸主，奥地利人真的不算太坏。他们建立了各种各样的农场，他们有葡萄园，他们有农业培训学院，他们在道路和铁路上花了很多钱。当然，这些铁路主要是为了他们自己的利益，为了他们的军队等等，但他们鼓励木材工业，他们鼓励萨拉热窝的采矿业，他们引入了电车系统，这后来为维也纳提供了模型，不是吗？他们确实做到了，汤姆。所以当我们去博物馆时，你知道，我们看到了博物馆里列出的那些成就，博物馆非常亲奥地利，它说哦，辉煌的砖厂，一条铺着沥青的可爱道路，
tremendous times and um they also uh they straighten out the river that runs through the middle of sarajevo it is a very imperial project yeah actually julius caesar wanted to do that to the tiber but that's by the by but they they straighten it out and then they put roads that are very straight on either side don't they and this will play a role in the story that is to come it will indeed theodore roosevelt in 1904 said you know america was now in taking possession of the philippines he said our model should be the austrians in bosnia they've been they've been brilliant now of course we can take this a little bit far. The illiteracy rate in Bosnia, for example, was woeful.
美好的时光，而且他们还拉直了流经萨拉热窝市中心的河流，这是一个非常帝国的项目。实际上，尤利乌斯·凯撒想对台伯河做同样的事，但那是题外话。但他们拉直了它，然后在两边修了非常笔直的道路，不是吗？这将对即将到来的故事起到作用。确实会。西奥多·罗斯福在 1904 年说，你知道，美国现在占领了菲律宾，他说我们的模型应该是奥地利人在波斯尼亚的做法，他们太棒了。当然，我们可以把这一点说得有点过头。例如，波斯尼亚的文盲率非常糟糕。
The Austrians had built new schools, 200 new primary schools, high schools and so on. But they were very unsuccessful in basically persuading Bosnian peasants to send their children to school, in persuading them that this was in their interest. Because the Bosnian peasants had a, they were opposed to education or because they thought that their children would be indoctrinated in Catholic Habsburg propaganda. I think there's that, absolutely that. And I think they feel like they need the kids working on the land. So as we'll see with Gavrilo Princip, his father is very resistant to him going away to school. Like, why would you not stay here and help on the,
奥地利人建造了新学校，200 所新小学、中学等等。但他们在说服波斯尼亚农民送孩子上学方面非常不成功，在说服他们这符合他们的利益方面非常不成功。因为波斯尼亚农民反对教育，或者因为他们认为他们的孩子会被灌输天主教哈布斯堡的宣传。我想有那个因素，绝对有。而且我认为他们觉得他们需要孩子在土地上工作。所以正如我们将看到的加夫里洛·普林西普，他的父亲非常抵制他去上学。就像，你为什么不留在这里帮忙，
you know, help me with the smallholding. So actually what you have is in the cities like Sarajevo, things are changing. They're modernizing very quickly. But in the rural hinterland, which is most of the country, life doesn't really change that much at all. Most, a lot of the peasants, certainly in Gavrilo Princip's area near Obliai, they are Orthodox. They see themselves as Bosnian Serbs. Life is still pretty tough for them. So if you take his parents, his parents called Petar and Maria. They were born in 1860. So they would have been teenagers when the Austrians marched in. Their life doesn't change very much at all.
你知道，帮我打理小农场。所以实际上你拥有的是，在萨拉热窝这样的城市，事情正在改变。它们正在迅速现代化。但在农村腹地，也就是这个国家的大部分地区，生活并没有发生太大的变化。大多数农民，当然是在奥布利亚伊附近的加夫里洛·普林西普地区，他们是东正教徒。他们认为自己是波斯尼亚塞族人。生活对他们来说仍然相当艰难。所以如果你看看他的父母，他的父母叫佩塔尔（Petar）和玛丽亚（Maria）。他们出生于 1860 年。所以当奥地利人进驻时，他们还是青少年。他们的生活并没有发生太大的变化。
They live in this cottage with livestock on the ground floor, and then they would live above it. It's here that Gavrilo was born in 1894. The story goes the family told Tim Butcher that he was originally going to be called Spiro but he was born on the Archangel Gabriel's day so Gavrilo is is Gavrilo is Gabriel Tim Butcher in the trigger says that he found in the ruins of the house a stone with written in Cyrillic GP it's got the photograph in the book. And the date, 1909. So that's basically the only evidence we have,
他们住在这个底层有牲畜的农舍里，然后他们住在上面。加夫里洛就是在这里于 1894 年出生的。故事是这样的，家人告诉蒂姆·布彻，他最初打算叫斯皮罗（Spiro），但他出生在天使长加百列的日子，所以加夫里洛就是加百列。蒂姆·布彻在《扳机》中说，他在房子的废墟中发现了一块石头，上面用西里尔字母写着 GP，书里有照片。日期是 1909 年。所以这基本上是我们拥有的唯一证据，
this one stone of Gavrilo Princip's childhood. He himself at his trial said how poor they were. We're treated like cattle. We have nothing. I know how tough it is in the villages. Probably it was when he was a little boy that he got the tuberculosis that would later kill him, that kills him before the end of the First World War. His father is quite religious. His father doesn't drink, which is very unusual
这块关于加夫里洛·普林西普童年的石头。他在审判时自己说他们有多穷。我们像牲畜一样被对待。我们一无所有。我知道村里的生活有多艰难。可能就是在他小时候，他得了后来杀死他的肺结核，这在第一次世界大战结束前就夺走了他的生命。他的父亲相当虔诚。他的父亲不喝酒，这在那个世界里非常罕见。
in that world. People are drinking their kind of slivovice, their plum and pear brandy. Meraki. Yeah, exactly. A kind of Meraki. But Petar doesn't drink. Petar is a big man in the village. He's the head of the local kind of association, earns a bit of extra money as the village postman. So he's ambitious to some degree within his limits. And both Gavrilo and his older brother, Jovo, have a degree of ambition. So Jovo goes away to work in a village near sarajevo in the timber industry basically dragging tree trunks to a sawmill and gavrilo who's grown up you know helping out with the chickens and the cow and the sheep and stuff he's obviously bright he's a good reader yeah so
人们喝他们的斯利沃维茨（slivovice），那种李子和梨白兰地。梅拉基（Meraki）。是的，完全正确。一种梅拉基。但佩塔尔不喝酒。佩塔尔是村里的重要人物。他是当地协会的负责人，作为村里的邮递员赚点外快。所以他在他的范围内有一定程度的野心。加夫里洛和他的哥哥约沃（Jovo）都有一定程度的野心。所以约沃去萨拉热窝附近的一个村庄从事木材工业，基本上是把树干拖到锯木厂，而加夫里洛，他长大后，你知道，帮忙照顾鸡、牛和羊之类的东西，他显然很聪明，他是个好读者，是的，所以
how does he learn to read there's a local school okay they go to the local school he learns to read and jovo when gavrilo is 13 jovo sees an advert in the newspaper so jovo also can read clearly yeah and jovo sees an advert that says as part of the austrian modernizing civilizing project as they would call it they want more people to go to school and there's an advert and it says basically send your children to sarajevo there are places in the schools. And so this is a very, very familiar story that will run throughout the 20th century, isn't it? Of imperial authorities setting up schools that then educate the people who will agitate against the imperial project.
他是怎么学会阅读的？有一所当地学校，好吧，他们去当地学校，他学会了阅读。当加夫里洛 13 岁时，约沃在报纸上看到了一则广告，所以约沃显然也能阅读，是的，约沃看到一则广告说，作为奥地利现代化文明项目的一部分，正如他们所称的那样，他们希望更多的人去上学，有一则广告说，基本上把你的孩子送到萨拉热窝，学校里有名额。所以这是一个非常、非常熟悉的故事，它将贯穿整个 20 世纪，不是吗？帝国当局建立学校，然后教育那些将煽动反对帝国项目的人。
Exactly. So basically, the worse empire you are, the more likely... So the Portuguese, for example. Yeah, none of that. You can keep it going indefinitely. Whereas if you're building schools and educating people and also bringing them to the metropole,
没错。所以基本上，你越是一个糟糕的帝国，就越有可能……所以葡萄牙人，例如。是的，什么都没有。你可以无限期地维持下去。而如果你在建立学校并教育人们，甚至把他们带到大都市，
like the British Empire does, to go to university, you're signing your own death warrant, Tom. Well, France Fanon. Yeah, absolutely. All that. Absolutely. So anyway,
就像大英帝国所做的那样，去上大学，你就是在签署自己的死亡令，汤姆。好吧，弗朗茨·法农（Frantz Fanon）。是的，绝对是。所有这些。绝对是。所以无论如何，
they have a family discussion. The father is not keen keen but the mother insists gavrilo is a bright boy this is a great opportunity for him he should go to sarajevo so in the late summer of 1907 he's 13 years old he and his father basically walk across a third of the country to get to the local railway station to get to the railway station so tim butcher in his book is has wonderful chapters about this they're walking through really remote mountains where there are wolves and bears and all the mines after the civil war now there are mines absolutely not back then obviously no they takes the majors they eventually get to the train how often have they been on a train probably never had a thought um they get the train to sarajevo and effectively gavrilo just 13 years old
他们进行了家庭讨论。父亲不太热心，但母亲坚持认为加夫里洛是个聪明的孩子，这对他是绝佳的机会，他应该去萨拉热窝。所以 1907 年夏末，他 13 岁时，他和父亲基本上步行穿过了该国的三分之一，才到达当地的火车站，去火车站。所以蒂姆·布彻在他的书中有关于此的精彩章节，他们走在非常偏远的山区，那里有狼和熊，还有内战后的所有地雷，现在有地雷，当时显然没有。他们最终坐上了火车，他们坐过多少次火车？可能从来没有。他们坐火车去萨拉热窝，实际上加夫里洛才 13 岁，
is dropped off and his father goes back to obliai and this cannot help but be an alienating experience so we've described how um gavrilo's experiences are kind of reminiscent of post-colonial thinkers and fighters and revolutionaries. But it's also very, very reminiscent of a whole strain in European literature in the 19th century. I guess Raskolnikov in Crime and Punishment, the ambitious young man going to Petersburg who has yearnings to be something and then finds not possible yeah and this is a kind of archetype that you see repeated again and again and again and gavrilo will kind of play this role won't he he's surrounded by what seems to him an overwhelming symbol of modernity
就被送到了那里，他的父亲回到了奥布利亚伊，这不可避免地成为一种疏离的经历。所以我们描述了加夫里洛的经历是如何让人想起后殖民思想家、战士和革命者的。但它也让人想起 19 世纪欧洲文学中的整个流派。我想是《罪与罚》中的拉斯柯尔尼科夫，那个雄心勃勃的年轻人去彼得堡，渴望成为某种人物，然后发现不可能，是的，这是一种你一次又一次看到的原型，加夫里洛将扮演这个角色，不是吗？他被他眼中压倒性的现代性象征所包围，
but actually isn't really is it i mean you've got the old tram and the odd straightened river yeah but in lots of ways it's a town of a kind that Byron might have recognized traveling in the Balkans a century earlier. It is. Sarajevo in 1907, when Gavrilo arrives, it's a fascinating place poised between, I mean, such a terrible cliche, but it's poised between old and new, Tom. Yeah. And east and west. Because to give people a sense, Sarajevo is strung along this valley, a pretty narrow valley. You've got hills on either side, the river running through it, the Milyatska, pretty small.
但实际上并不是，不是吗？我的意思是，你有旧电车和奇怪的拉直河流，是的，但在很多方面，这是一个拜伦一个世纪前在巴尔干半岛旅行时可能认出的那种城镇。确实是。1907 年加夫里洛到达萨拉热窝时，这是一个迷人的地方，介于——我的意思是，这是一个非常糟糕的陈词滥调，但它介于新旧之间，汤姆。是的。以及东方和西方。为了让人们有个概念，萨拉热窝沿着这个山谷延伸，一个相当狭窄的山谷。两边都有山，河流穿过它，米利亚茨卡河（Milyatska），相当小。
It's not a massive river. The sides of the river are kind of lined with big Austrian buildings. I mean, we're surrounded by them, very obviously Habsburg-era buildings. But there's also the mosques that the Ottomans had built. There's a kind of bizarre quarter that we were walking around earlier. Now with all kinds of souvenir shops and stuff, it feels, even today, it feels very Turkish. Yeah, it does. I mean, there are a lot of mosques and there are a lot of women in headscarves, some of them veiled. And I guess that a century ago, that was even more apparent.
它不是一条大河。河流两岸排列着大型奥地利建筑。我的意思是，我们被它们包围着，非常明显是哈布斯堡时代的建筑。但也有奥斯曼人建造的清真寺。我们早些时候走过一个奇怪的街区。现在有各种各样的纪念品商店之类的，即使在今天，它也感觉非常土耳其。是的，确实。我的意思是，有很多清真寺，有很多戴头巾的妇女，其中一些戴着面纱。我想一个世纪前，这一点更加明显。
Even more so. Arthur Evans, the Gnosis guy, had said, the Bosnian countryman gapes with as much wonderment at the domes of the two chief mosques in Sarajevo as an English rustic at the first sight of St. Paul's. Now, of course, for Gavrilo Princip, it's not just that these are bigger buildings than he's ever seen, but they're Islamic. He is an Orthodox Christian.
更是如此。那个诺斯（Gnosis）专家亚瑟·埃文斯曾说，波斯尼亚乡下人对萨拉热窝两座主要清真寺圆顶的惊叹，就像英国乡下人第一次看到圣保罗大教堂一样。当然，对于加夫里洛·普林西普来说，这不仅是因为这些建筑比他见过的任何建筑都大，而且它们是伊斯兰教的。他是一名东正教基督徒。
And Islam for a Serb peasant is representative of the ruling class. Yeah. I mean, difficult for the people in Western cities to think of. Yeah. It's the reverse of what prevails now. Exactly. So he would have come here and he would have seen people in fezzes and turbans and the kind of baggy trousers and stuff. He would have seen a lot fezes and turbans and the kind of baggy trousers
对于一个塞族农民来说，伊斯兰教代表了统治阶级。是的。我的意思是，西方城市的人很难想到这一点。是的。这与现在盛行的正好相反。没错。所以他来到这里，他会看到戴着土耳其帽和头巾的人，以及那种宽松的裤子之类的。他会看到很多戴着土耳其帽和头巾的人，以及那种宽松的裤子
and stuff he would have seen a lot of women with veils which would not have been the case back in obliai he would as you said have seen the trams government offices a tram just went past us now the austrian buildings like the theater and so on as you said obviously the austrians have just rerouted the river so i think all of this is clearly a big culture shock. There's a story told by Vladimir Dedio in his book, The Road to Sarajevo, that when Princip arrives, he and his brother go to this guest house, which is run by a Muslim innkeeper who is wearing traditional Muslim dress. And Princip is supposed, Gavrilo was supposed to have said,
之类的，他会看到很多戴面纱的妇女，这在奥布利亚伊是不可能有的。正如你所说，他会看到电车、政府办公室，刚才一辆电车从我们身边经过，奥地利建筑，比如剧院等等，正如你所说，显然奥地利人刚刚改道了河流，所以我认为所有这些显然是一个巨大的文化冲击。弗拉基米尔·德迪耶在他的书《通往萨拉热窝之路》中讲了一个故事，当普林西普到达时，他和他的哥哥去了这家旅馆，旅馆由一位穿着传统穆斯林服装的穆斯林旅店老板经营。普林西普应该，加夫里洛应该说过，
I don't want to sleep here because these people are Turks. turks so been comparing him to figures from 19th century literature but you could also i guess compare him to the deracinated guy who goes on to become a terrorist in the 21st century christopher clark in the introduction to sleepwalkers actually makes this point he says that you know looking back to the pre-war world guys in feathers and archdukes and things but actually this is a world that will be very familiar to people who've lived through 9-11 or the london tube bombings the kind of people who are committing those atrocities are people who feel dislocated from the expressions of modernity that surround them but are also culturally alienated from the mainstream dominant culture that they regard with contempt and hatred.
我不想睡在这里，因为这些人是土耳其人。土耳其人。所以一直在把他与 19 世纪文学中的人物进行比较，但我想你也可以把他与 21 世纪成为恐怖分子的那种被连根拔起的人进行比较。克里斯托弗·克拉克在《梦游者》的引言中实际上指出了这一点，他说，回顾战前的世界，戴着羽毛的人和大公等等，但实际上这是一个对经历过 9-11 或伦敦地铁爆炸案的人来说非常熟悉的世界，那些犯下这些暴行的人是那些感到与周围的现代性表达脱节的人，但也从文化上疏远了主流统治文化，他们带着蔑视和仇恨看待这种文化。
Absolutely, Tom. I totally agree. As we will see in the rest of today's podcast, Gavrilo Princip, lonely, idealistic, quite bright, poor, alienated from the culture that surrounds him, disaffected, all of these things he conforms completely to a stereotype with which we are now very very sort of tragically familiar
绝对是，汤姆。我完全同意。正如我们将在今天播客的其余部分看到的那样，加夫里洛·普林西普，孤独、理想主义、相当聪明、贫穷、与周围的文化疏远、不满，所有这些事情，他完全符合我们现在非常、非常悲剧性地熟悉的刻板印象。
at first actually you know he seems to make a decent start his brother finds him a lodging with a bosnian sub widow who is called mrslic. We will come back to this family later on. So it's on the edge of the Bazaar Court. It's very close to where we are now. So when he looks out of his window, he can see... The wailing of the muazen. Exactly, all of that stuff. He goes to a place called the Merchant School,
起初，他似乎有一个不错的开始，他哥哥为他找了一位名叫伊利奇夫人的波斯尼亚寡妇的住处。我们稍后再回到这个家庭。它就在集市广场的边缘，离我们现在所在的地方非常近。所以当他从窗户往外看时，他能看到……穆安津的哀鸣。没错，就是这些东西。他去了一个叫商学院的地方，
which is a commercial school that is basically designed to educate you to be a tradesman or a shopkeeper or something like that. And just to point out, he is getting money from his parents. So they are sufficiently big figures in their small village that they can send money to him. But not much money. But it is greatly to his credit that he kind of will, over the course of his time in Sarajevo, share that with his friends. Yes, he does. He does.
那是一所商业学校，基本上是为了培养商人、店主或类似职业的人而设计的。顺便提一下，他当时从父母那里得到钱。所以他们在他们的小村庄里算是足够有头有脸的人物，能够给他寄钱。但钱不多。不过，他在萨拉热窝期间愿意与朋友分享这些钱，这非常值得称赞。是的，他确实这么做了。他确实这么做了。
That's probably the one nice thing we're going to say about Gavrilo Princip in this entire story. He's a generous, generous lad. So Tim Butcher, in his book, The Trigger, has done amazing detective work on his school reports and his school grades. He tracked down the school records. And it tells a really fascinating and frankly familiar story. He starts, he's very clever, he's dedicated, he does really well. He
这可能是我们在整个故事中关于加夫里洛·普林西普唯一能说的优点了。他是一个慷慨、慷慨的年轻人。蒂姆·布彻在他的书《导火索》中，对他的学校报告和成绩做了惊人的侦探工作。他追踪到了学校记录。这讲述了一个非常迷人且坦率地说很熟悉的故事。他刚开始时非常聪明，很专注，表现得非常好。他
gets straight A's, he gets a first class diploma with honors at the end of his first year. So this is 13-14. But in the next few years, the story is one of steady decline. His grades get worse and worse. Crucially, I think I think that Butcher finds from the records that it's really important, his address keeps changing. That is a sign of instability and poverty, I think, that he is moving between different places and clearly running out of money. And that's something, again, that is very familiar from the life patterns of hijackers and terrorists in the 21st century yeah absolutely so as butcher says the reports tell a story of a student going inexorably off the rails actually so by 1910
成绩全优，第一学年结束时获得了荣誉一等文凭。那是13-14岁的时候。但在接下来的几年里，故事变成了持续的衰落。他的成绩越来越差。关键的是，我认为布彻从记录中发现了一点非常重要，那就是他的住址一直在变。我认为这是不稳定和贫困的迹象，他不断在不同的地方搬迁，显然钱快花光了。这一点，再次说明，与21世纪劫机者和恐怖分子的生活模式非常相似。是的，绝对是这样。正如布彻所说，这些报告讲述了一个学生不可避免地走上歧途的故事。实际上，到了1910年，
he's still ambitious he's been here three years he leaves the merchant school with his parents permission and he goes to actually a more elite school the gymnasium the gymnasium which is an austro-hungarian foundation was one of the first things the Austrians did was to build this high school, which was a school where you would go right through to the end and then possibly go to university. So it's the medium for that German? No, I don't think it is, Tom, because we know that later on he needs help translating a German newspaper from one of his friends. So he's not as familiar with germany german is the language of the occupier and there was a movement of bright kids like him who are going to schools and colleges in bosnia at this period are often kicking against the occupier refusing to learn or to speak german so that school was very close to where we are now it's just off what's called the apple key
他依然雄心勃勃，他已经在这里待了三年，在父母的许可下，他离开了商学院，去了一所更精英的学校——文理中学。文理中学是奥匈帝国的基石，奥地利人做的第一件事就是建立这所高中，这是一所你可以一直读到毕业，然后可能去上大学的学校。所以这是德语的媒介吗？不，我不这么认为，汤姆，因为我们知道后来他需要朋友帮他翻译德语报纸。所以他对德语并不熟悉。德语是占领者的语言，当时像他这样聪明的孩子在波斯尼亚的学校和学院里，经常反抗占领者，拒绝学习或说德语。所以那所学校离我们现在的地方非常近，就在所谓的苹果码头附近，
and that key is the straight road straight road running along the river of arguably i mean this is a big statement you could argue that is the most consequential road in modern european history as we will as we will find out but he gets terrible grades at the gymnasium i'm reminded of actually of hitler when hitler changed school and went to i think lintz the big, a lonely idealistic boy, his grades plummeted. And that's what happens with Gavrilo. And it's a similar milieu, isn't it? Hitler is in Vienna. So they're both living in the same imperial framework. And it's this kind of land, this dimension of Doss houses,
那条码头是沿着河流的一条笔直的道路，可以说——这是一个很大的说法，你可以说它是现代欧洲历史上最重要的道路，正如我们将要发现的那样。但他在这所文理中学的成绩非常糟糕。我实际上想到了希特勒，当希特勒转学去林茨时，那个孤独、理想主义的男孩，他的成绩一落千丈。加夫里洛也是如此。环境很相似，不是吗？希特勒在维也纳。所以他们都生活在同一个帝国框架内。这就是那种充满廉价公寓、
frustrated intellectuals, and fervent nationalism. And the question is, of course, in Princip's case, where is this nationalism coming from? And I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, let's look at that and see what are the wellsprings of Serbian nationalism in Princip's Sarajevo. Kiara. It means smart in Italian. Too bad your barista can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name. Your cafe name. Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection.
受挫的知识分子和狂热民族主义的土地和维度。当然，问题在于，在普林西普的案例中，这种民族主义从何而来？我想我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们看看这一点，看看普林西普所在的萨拉热窝，塞尔维亚民族主义的源头是什么。基亚拉。在意大利语中是聪明的意思。可惜你的咖啡师拼不对。所以你只能给一个假名字。你的咖啡馆名字。朱莉娅。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在证人保护计划中。
Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this. Because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢什么样的浓缩咖啡饮料？现在改你的拿铁订单太晚了吗？但有了KitchenAid的浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些想法了。因为你本可以在家里自己做浓缩咖啡。现在就去KitchenAid.ca选购吧。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello and welcome back to The Rest Is History and Dominic, we are looking at the making of Gavrilo Princip, assassin of Franz Ferdinand here in Sarajevo, where we are currently sitting. I think the sense that I probably had before looking at this was that Bosnia was a powder keg. Yeah.
我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》，多米尼克，我们正在研究加夫里洛·普林西普的成长历程，他是弗朗茨·斐迪南在萨拉热窝的刺客，我们现在就坐在这里。我想在研究这个之前，我可能觉得波斯尼亚是一个火药桶。是的。
But actually, it doesn't seem to have been that much of a powder keg, really. No, I would say not particularly. So if people are thinking it's this kind of seething with nationalist discontent. Ancient hatred. Ancient hatred. I think that is not right. So in 1914, there were about two million people. A third of them are Muslim.
但实际上，它似乎并没有那么像一个火药桶。不，我会说并不是特别像。所以如果人们认为这里充满了民族主义的不满。古老的仇恨。古老的仇恨。我认为那是不对的。所以1914年，这里大约有两百万人。其中三分之一是穆斯林。
A quarter of them are Catholic. That means they would call themselves Bosnian Croats, and they'd identify with their Catholic neighbor, Croatia, which is part of the Austro-Hungarian Empire. And then the rest, so we're talking just under half, they would be Orthodox, and they would call themselves Bosnian Serbs. By the way, all these figures are much contested. Yeah, I'm sure. Of course. Nationalist historians on various sides argue bitterly about them. However, that I think is a reasonable estimate. Now, it is absolutely true. The Austrians have great trouble in making the politics of Bosnia work because often these people spend an enormous amount of
四分之一是天主教徒。这意味着他们会称自己为波斯尼亚克罗地亚人，并认同他们的天主教邻国克罗地亚，那是奥匈帝国的一部分。剩下的，也就是不到一半，他们是东正教徒，他们会称自己为波斯尼亚塞尔维亚人。顺便说一句，所有这些数字都存在很大争议。是的，我肯定。当然。各方的民族主义历史学家对这些数字争论不休。然而，我认为这是一个合理的估计。现在，绝对真实的是，奥地利人在处理波斯尼亚的政治问题上遇到了很大的麻烦，因为这些人经常花费大量
time squabbling among themselves and demanding patronage, funding, all of those kinds of things, and refusing to work together. So that is a big issue. However, this is not an especially violent place. After the 1870s, there are not huge uprisings. It is not as stable as the Austrians would like, by any means. But say to compare it with another part of pre-war Europe that we've done, Ireland, pre-1914. Would Ireland be more unstable, do you think?
时间在内部争吵，要求赞助、资金以及所有这类事情，并拒绝合作。所以这是一个大问题。然而，这并不是一个特别暴力的地方。1870年代之后，没有发生过大规模的起义。它绝不像奥地利人希望的那样稳定。但如果把它与我们做过的战前欧洲的另一个部分——1914年前的爱尔兰——相比较呢？你认为爱尔兰会更不稳定吗？
I would say you would think that Ireland would be a greater... Our Irish listeners will not enjoy being described as a problem, so I do that kind of advisedly. But for the imperial power? For the imperial authorities, I think the British would have regarded ireland as more of a pressing problem than the austrians would have thought about bosnia i think the issue tom is that actually for most people most people as so often are just getting along with their normal
我会说你会认为爱尔兰会是一个更大的……我们的爱尔兰听众不会喜欢被描述为一个问题，所以我说得比较谨慎。但对于帝国权力来说呢？对于帝国当局，我认为英国人会把爱尔兰视为比奥地利人看待波斯尼亚更紧迫的问题。汤姆，我认为问题在于，实际上对大多数人来说，就像往常一样，他们只是在过着正常的
lives the people who are the problem as it were are actually people like gavrilo princip they are literate idealistic students so these are the people like Gavrilo Princip. They are literate, idealistic students. So these are the people who everywhere in Europe at this point are the most susceptible to the most exciting and fashionable creed of the day, which is nationalism. But also a kind of anarchism as well. Yeah. Socialism. So, I mean, all those presidents and prime ministers and monarchs that I described being shot. Yeah. There's the kind of strain of mingled anarchism and nationalism there. Yes. And it's very much present here in Sarajevo.
生活。那些所谓的问题人物实际上是像加夫里洛·普林西普这样的人，他们是受过教育的、理想主义的学生。所以这些人就像加夫里洛·普林西普。他们是受过教育的、理想主义的学生。所以这些人是当时欧洲各地最容易受到最令人兴奋和时髦的信条——民族主义——影响的人。但也有一种无政府主义。是的。社会主义。所以，我的意思是，我描述的那些被枪杀的总统、总理和君主。是的。那里有一种混合了无政府主义和民族主义的倾向。是的。而且它在萨拉热窝非常普遍。
Totally. And actually, of course, the funny thing is that the Austrian modernization project, which is building libraries and which sees the establishment of coffee houses and youth clubs and all these things, those are the milieu in which these ideas are being exchanged. So they are actually creating, they are facilitating the expression of this kind of discontent. Now, most of that activism is pretty low level. So you would see, if we'd been where we are right now, in this kind of lovely little street
完全正确。而且，当然，有趣的是，奥地利的现代化项目，即建造图书馆，以及咖啡馆和青年俱乐部的建立，这些都是这些思想交流的环境。所以他们实际上是在创造、促进这种不满情绪的表达。现在，大部分的激进主义都是相当低水平的。所以你会看到，如果我们现在就在这里，在这个可爱的街道上，
in Sarajevo in 1914, we'd have seen maybe graffiti denouncing Schwaben, Swabians, which was the kind of nickname given, you know, they're kind of Teutons. Brits out. Yeah, that kind of equivalent. We'd have seen that. We might have seen scribbling over German language signs. So like Corsica. Yeah, absolutely.
在1914年的萨拉热窝，我们可能已经看到涂鸦谴责“施瓦本”（Schwaben），这是给他们的绰号，你知道，他们是某种条顿人。英国人滚出去。是的，类似的东西。我们可能已经看到了。我们可能已经看到德语标志被涂抹。就像科西嘉岛一样。是的，绝对是。
But most of that, that's not an existential threat. Right, it's not paramilitaries being recruited in Belfast. No, it's not. Kind of level threat. No, it's not.ilitaries being recruited in Belfast. No, it's not a level threat. No, it's not. And the Austrians tried to shut that down. So in 1913, they shut down the high school in Mostar because of nationalist agitation. They actually arrested almost 150 secondary school children and put them on trial for kind of anti-Austrian demonstrations and stuff. But obviously, they're never going to shut all this down because the more they educate people the more trouble they are going to have and gavrilo princip is
但大部分，那不是生存威胁。对，那不是在贝尔法斯特招募的准军事部队。不，不是。那种级别的威胁。不，不是。准军事部队在贝尔法斯特招募。不，那不是那种级别的威胁。不，不是。奥地利人试图阻止这种情况。所以1913年，他们因为民族主义煽动关闭了莫斯塔尔的高中。他们实际上逮捕了近150名中学生，并以反奥地利示威等罪名审判他们。但显然，他们永远无法阻止这一切，因为他们教育的人越多，他们遇到的麻烦就越多，而加夫里洛·普林西普
absolutely typical of this generation so he is a reader as a personality he is he's your classic introvert he's a loner the other boys so, when they're interviewed after he's become famous, when one of them said, he stood out, he pretended that he knew more than any of us about literature. He used to say, he used to boast that he was the cleverest of us. So he's like, do you know what he reminds me of? Lee Harvey Oswald. Lee Harvey Oswald. I mean, amazingly like Lee Harvey Oswald.
绝对是这一代人的典型。所以他是一个读者，作为一个个性，他是典型的内向者，一个孤独者。其他男孩，当他在成名后被采访时，其中一个人说，他很突出，他假装自己比我们任何人都懂文学。他过去常说，他吹嘘自己是我们中最聪明的。所以他就像，你知道他让我想起了谁吗？李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德。李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德。我的意思是，非常像李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德。
Yeah. Or your kind of American high school shooter. Yeah. You know, the boy who sits alone sneers at the others in the cast thinks he knows more spending all his evenings on the internet yeah gavrilo princip mark david chapman he is that boy yeah i mean we know that he read he loved reading he loved oscar wilde he also loves alexander dumas and sherlock holmes he loves sherlock holmes and walter scott these are the stories that are being reprinted
是的。或者那种美国高中枪手。是的。你知道，那个独自坐着、嘲笑其他人、认为自己知道得更多、整晚都在上网的男孩。是的，加夫里洛·普林西普，马克·大卫·查普曼，他就是那个男孩。是的，我的意思是，我们知道他读过书，他热爱阅读，他热爱奥斯卡·王尔德，他也热爱亚历山大·仲马和夏洛克·福尔摩斯。他热爱夏洛克·福尔摩斯和沃尔特·司各特，这些都是当时被重印的故事，
in Serbo-Croat language as it would then have been called Serbo-Croat language journals so there's there's a piece of writing isn't there
用塞尔维亚-克罗地亚语，当时被称为塞尔维亚-克罗地亚语期刊。所以有一篇写作，不是吗？
basically the only piece of writing that survived by him yeah by him that's written when he was 16 that anyone who has fancied themselves
基本上是他留下的唯一一篇写作，是的，是他写的，那是他16岁时写的，任何自认为
as being good at writing english yeah we'll recognize quite adrian mole we left hajichi hadzichi oh tom what is it at sunset when the western sun was blazing in purple splendor when the numberless rays of the blood-red sun filled the whole sky and when the whole nature was preparing to sleep through the beautiful dreamy summer evening in the magic peace that beloved ideal night of the poet now i wrote a lot of essays like that yeah fair i didn't go on to become a murderer you're still time tom there is there is but it's a young man's game really though isn't it i mean that's the key it's actually i don't think it's that bad no it's not it was as if we were hearing the song of the four sirens and the sad
擅长英语写作的人，是的，都会认出这很像阿德里安·莫尔。我们离开了哈吉奇，哈吉奇，哦，汤姆，那是什么？在日落时分，当西方的太阳在紫色的光辉中燃烧，当血红色的太阳的无数光芒填满了整个天空，当整个自然界准备在美丽的梦幻般的夏日傍晚中入睡，在那种宁静的魔力中，诗人所钟爱的理想之夜。现在，我写了很多那样的文章。是的，公平地说，我没有成为一个杀人犯。你还有时间，汤姆，还有时间，但那确实是年轻人的游戏，不是吗？我的意思是，那是关键，其实我不认为那有那么糟糕。不，那不糟糕，那就像我们听到了四位海妖的歌声和神圣的奥尔菲斯那悲伤的
aeolian harp of divine orpheus yeah no it's not bad i mean it's not an idiot it's overwritten it's romantic yeah it's lush and there's perhaps the faint hint of self-pity totally but that's very romantic too right but it's very also very teenage, isn't it? Everything about teenagers, a word that hasn't yet been invented, that will come to kind of shake the world, actually in the post-Second World War world, but is already clearly kind of fermenting here. Totally. Absolutely it is, Tom. The two things we know about him as a teenager,
风神竖琴。是的，不，那不糟糕，我的意思是，它不是白痴写的，它写得过火了，它是浪漫的。是的，它是华丽的，也许还有一丝淡淡的自怜。完全正确，但这也非常浪漫，对吧？但这也非常、非常青少年，不是吗？关于青少年的一切，一个尚未被发明的词，它将在第二次世界大战后的世界里震撼世界，但显然已经在此时此地发酵了。完全正确。绝对是这样，汤姆。关于他作为青少年的两件事，我们知道，
number one, he's very, very poor. So he spends all his money really on books. You're absolutely right that he is seen by his friends as quite generous. He will share money with his friends and so on. But after the first couple of years, I think our sense is he is surviving on loans. He's borrowing a lot of money and his brother is helping him out. Yeah. And that obviously, when you're a teenager, makes you frustrated and angry and he's lonely he doesn't drink his father didn't drink of course
第一，他非常、非常穷。所以他真的把所有的钱都花在书上了。你说得完全对，他被朋友们视为相当慷慨。他会和朋友分享钱等等。但在最初的几年之后，我想我们的感觉是他靠贷款生存。他借了很多钱，他哥哥在帮他。是的。而且显然，当你是一个青少年时，这会让你感到沮丧和愤怒，而且他很孤独。他不喝酒，他父亲当然也不喝酒。
yeah he doesn't drink in a place like Sarajevo full of cafes full of activity you know people sitting outside smoking and drinking that would presumably make him stand out a bit plus we were talking about this on the walk about whether this is a key factor or not i think it actually is an important thing he's an incel he doesn't have a girlfriend yeah he doesn't there's one girl that he supposedly liked but he never you know even picked up the courage to talk to her as he later tells his austrian psychiatrist when he's in prison who Who's not Dr. Freud. No.
是的，他不喝酒，在一个像萨拉热窝这样到处都是咖啡馆、到处都是活动的地方，你知道人们坐在外面抽烟喝酒，这大概会让他显得有点格格不入。另外，我们刚才在散步时谈到了这是否是一个关键因素，我认为这确实是一个重要的事情。他是一个非自愿独身者（incel），他没有女朋友。是的，他没有。有一个女孩他据说喜欢，但他从来没有（你知道）鼓起勇气去和她说话，正如他后来在监狱里告诉他的奥地利精神病医生那样，那个不是弗洛伊德医生的人。不。
But I think, you know, so often we see with people who commit terrorist acts that they are lonely, frustrated. You know, you made the joke about being an incel. Well, it wasn't a joke. It was a serious point. Yeah. So he does have one friend who I think is very influential on him. You'll remember that when he first moved to Sarajevo, he moved in with the widow Illich, Mrs. Illich. She had a son who was 17 when he arrived. So you can absolutely see if you're 13 and there's a 17 year old in the house, he will influence you. And he's the perfect
但我认为，你知道，我们经常看到那些实施恐怖行为的人，他们是孤独的、沮丧的。你知道，你开了关于他是非自愿独身者的玩笑。嗯，那不是玩笑。那是一个严肃的观点。是的。所以他确实有一个朋友，我认为对他非常有影响力。你会记得当他第一次搬到萨拉热窝时，他搬进了伊利奇寡妇，伊利奇夫人的家里。她有一个儿子，他到达时17岁。所以你可以完全看出，如果你13岁，家里有一个17岁的人，他会影响你。而且他是完美的
kind of person to influence Gavrilo. He's called Danilo Illich. He trained as a teacher, but he didn't really settle down. He ended up actually becoming a proofreader for a newspaper he is tall he is emaciated and he he always wears a black tie doesn't he yes as a constant reminder of death i mean that's basically if you're a 13 year old and you're hanging out with a 17 year old who's talking in that kind of way yeah he has a kind of cool mustache yeah i mean you're getting a hero worship him you are absolutely now danilo illich i think i think it's fair to say that as a father myself he's not the influence i would choose all kinds of reasons he spends his free time translating uh bakunin maxim gorky oscar wilde
那种能影响加夫里洛的人。他叫达尼洛·伊利奇。他受过教师培训，但他并没有真正安定下来。他最终实际上成为了一家报纸的校对员。他很高，他很消瘦，而且他总是打着黑领带，不是吗？是的，作为死亡的持续提醒。我的意思是，基本上如果你是一个13岁的孩子，你和一个17岁的人混在一起，他以那种方式说话，是的，他有一种很酷的胡子。是的，我的意思是，你正在崇拜他。你绝对是。现在达尼洛·伊利奇，我想，我想说作为一名父亲，他不是我会选择的影响，出于各种原因。他把空闲时间花在翻译巴枯宁、马克西姆·高尔基、奥斯卡·王尔德上。
again tom he loves nietzsche. He's just so annoying. He was clearly an incredibly annoying person. Sounds like me. It's like a young Tom Holland. But he was also really into politics. So he would travel. What money Illich had, he would spend traveling. He was as far as Switzerland, for example.
又是汤姆，他热爱尼采。他真是太烦人了。他显然是一个极其烦人的人。听起来像我。就像年轻的汤姆·霍兰德。但他也非常热衷于政治。所以他会旅行。伊利奇有什么钱，他就会花在旅行上。他甚至去过瑞士，例如。
Switzerland, the great destination for emigres, for Marxist emigres. Lenin was there. Illich would go to these places to basically buy revolutionary pamphlets, political tracts and stuff. Then he'd come back to Sarajevo, sit around with his other fellow incels, and they would discuss these tracts
瑞士，流亡者的伟大目的地，马克思主义流亡者的目的地。列宁就在那里。伊利奇会去这些地方，基本上是为了购买革命小册子、政治传单之类的东西。然后他会回到萨拉热窝，和其他非自愿独身者朋友坐在一起，他们会讨论这些传单
and say, oh, isn't this amazing? I mean, it's a very, very kind of pre-war version of the radical internet oh isn't this amazing i mean it's it's a very very um a kind of pre-war version of the radical internet isn't it absolutely it's people downloading dodgy stuff on the internet yeah gathering around to read it or it's the or it's a political version of the the the teenager in the 70s who has actually gone to america and brought loads of records and brought them back to england sharing them with his friends it just happens to be revolutionary tracks and they're all thinking all those you know all the jihadis and so on oh yeah they were kind of accessing um illegal
然后说，哦，这不是很棒吗？我的意思是，这是一种非常、非常战前的激进互联网版本。哦，这不是很棒吗？我的意思是，这是一种非常、非常……一种战前的激进互联网版本，不是吗？绝对是，这是人们在互联网上下载不正经的东西，是的，聚集在一起阅读，或者它是70年代那个去过美国并带回大量唱片并带回英国与朋友分享的青少年的政治版本。这恰好是革命性的传单，他们都在想，所有那些，你知道，所有的圣战分子等等，哦是的，他们是在访问……非法
websites to download yeah screeds from azam bin laden or whatever exactly you're absolutely right that's what illich is doing and that undoubtedly rubs off on gavrilo Princip. Now Gavrilo Princip remember arrived here in 1907. In 1908 the following year so when he is 14, 15 very impressionable there is a huge political crisis and what happens is that Austria has been administering Bosnia for 30 years but now the austrians say we will formally annex bosnia herzegovina you know the days of ottoman sovereignty are completely gone and their plan is basically we will fully incorporate bosnia into the hapsburg empire and they have a good reason for doing that what they want to do is they want to have a better balance within the hapsburg empire of german speakers magyar speakers, i.e. Hungarians,
网站来下载……奥萨马·本·拉登或其他人的长篇大论。完全正确，你说得完全对，这就是伊利奇在做的事情，这无疑影响了加夫里洛·普林西普。现在加夫里洛·普林西普，记住，是1907年到达这里的。1908年，第二年，所以当他14、15岁，非常容易受影响的时候，发生了一场巨大的政治危机。发生的事情是，奥地利已经管理波斯尼亚30年了，但现在奥地利人说我们将正式吞并波斯尼亚和黑塞哥维那，你知道，奥斯曼主权的时代已经完全结束了，他们的计划基本上是我们会将波斯尼亚完全纳入哈布斯堡帝国，他们这样做有一个很好的理由，他们想做的是在哈布斯堡帝国内部实现德语使用者、马扎尔语使用者（即匈牙利人）之间更好的平衡，
and Slavs. So what the authorities want to do is actually they want a balance actually against the Hungarians. And having more Slavs means they can perhaps establish a separate, a third kingdom, a third element of that bifurcated empire, a Slav kingdom with the emperor as its monarch, and that will mean greater stability in the long run. It's very controversial for all kinds of diplomatic reasons, which we won't go into in this episode. But what Gavrilo would have seen straight away, there would have been protests from people who are opposed to the Austrians. But he would also have seen the apparatus of Austro-Hungarian rule becoming much more pronounced. So lots of new people arrive in Sarajevo. The Austrian authorities are given more powers.
以及斯拉夫人。所以当局想做的是，实际上他们想平衡匈牙利人。拥有更多的斯拉夫人意味着他们也许可以建立一个独立的、第三个王国，那个二元帝国的第三个要素，一个以皇帝为君主的斯拉夫王国，这将意味着长期的更大稳定。由于各种外交原因，这非常有争议，我们不会在本集中深入探讨。但加夫里洛会立刻看到，会有来自反对奥地利人的民众的抗议。但他也会看到奥匈帝国的统治机构变得更加明显。所以很多新的人来到萨拉热窝。奥地利当局被赋予了更多的权力。
And actually, the census tells the story. So we know that by 1910, the Catholic population of Sarajevo has gone up in three decades from 700 to 17,000 out of about 50,000. And those Catholics are Austrians. They are Hungarians. They are Croats. They are newcomers who are affiliated to the imperial regime. So for Scavrillo and his friends, you can imagine how angry they are about that. Loads of new people, hundreds and thousands of them.
而且实际上，人口普查说明了一切。所以我们知道，到1910年，萨拉热窝的天主教人口在三十年内从700人增加到了50,000人中的17,000人。而那些天主教徒是奥地利人。他们是匈牙利人。他们是克罗地亚人。他们是隶属于帝国政权的新来者。所以对于加夫里洛和他的朋友们来说，你可以想象他们对此有多愤怒。大量的新人，成千上万的人。
Getting swamped. Swamped by immigrants. That's what they're thinking. So we can see, I mean, we see this in Gavrilo's later statements. There is an intense bitterness towards Vienna, towards Austria. He says they hate the South Slavs. They're evil to us. He says, if I could, I would wipe Austria from the map.
被淹没了。被移民淹没了。这就是他们的想法。所以我们可以看到，我的意思是，我们在加夫里洛后来的陈述中看到了这一点。对维也纳、对奥地利有一种强烈的苦涩。他说他们憎恨南斯拉夫人。他们对我们很邪恶。他说，如果可以，我会把奥地利从地图上抹去。
I hate Austria so much. And a lot of that, I think, is the classic exaggerated anger of a teenager, of a romantic teenager. But it's also, I mean, it is reminiscent of Hitler again, isn't it? The anxiety that a nation, the idea of a nation that you cherish is being swamped by alien peoples and alien cultures. Yeah, absolutely it is. And I think that explains why,
我非常憎恨奥地利。我认为其中很多是青少年、浪漫的青少年那种典型的夸张愤怒。但它也，我的意思是，这再次让人想起希特勒，不是吗？那种焦虑，即你珍视的国家被外来民族和外来文化所淹没。是的，绝对是。而且我认为这解释了为什么，
so in 1908 or so, Gavrilo is dragged not towards socialism, which was, of course, on the table. Yeah, he's reading Oscar Wilde. Yeah, he's reading Kropotkin and stuff, anarchist books. He reads William Morris. So he could have become a wallpaper designer had history been different. Yes, he could have done. Absolutely, he could have become a wallpaper designer had history been different
所以在1908年左右，加夫里洛并没有被拉向社会主义，尽管那当然是摆在桌面上的。是的，他在读奥斯卡·王尔德。是的，他在读克鲁泡特金之类的无政府主义书籍。他读威廉·莫里斯。所以如果历史不同的话，他本可以成为一名壁纸设计师。是的，他本可以。绝对，如果历史不同的话，他本可以成为一名壁纸设计师。
like yes he could have done absolutely he could have been a great advocate for arts and crafts but sadly different history would have history yeah but what it is is is Slav nationalism that seduces him and it's important actually to make this point because I think again lots of people in fact loads of historians get this wrong they describe him as a Serb nationalist, and that's not really right. He's literally a Yugoslav nationalist, South Slav nationalist. He thinks all of the South Slavic peoples should be united in one state, admittedly under the leadership of Serbia, but not purely as a... It's a Yugoslavia that he wants, not a Serbia.
就像是的，他本可以。绝对，他本可以成为艺术与工艺运动的伟大倡导者，但遗憾的是，不同的历史会有历史，是的。但它实际上是斯拉夫民族主义诱惑了他，而且实际上提出这一点很重要，因为我认为再次，很多人，事实上大量的历史学家搞错了这一点。他们把他描述为塞尔维亚民族主义者，那并不完全正确。他实际上是南斯拉夫民族主义者，南斯拉夫民族主义者。他认为所有的南斯拉夫民族应该在一个国家内统一，诚然是在塞尔维亚的领导下，但不是纯粹作为……他想要的是南斯拉夫，而不是塞尔维亚。
And the movement that expresses that that he gets into is this militant group called malada bosnia young bosnia and this is a very loose alliance of talking shops so-called revolutionary cells well groups of kids in cafes i see in your notes that you've you've written literally woke their credo the whole of our society is snoring ungracefully only the poets and revolutionaries are awake that's exactly it very 19th century it's very shelly could have written absolutely everybody else is sleeping you know all the peasants that he thinks should be fighting the Austrians, they're actually just like, they don't give a damn about this. They're looking after their chickens.
而表达这一点的运动，他加入的那个激进组织叫“青年波斯尼亚”（Mlada Bosna），这是一个非常松散的谈话俱乐部联盟，所谓的革命小组，嗯，咖啡馆里的孩子群。我在你的笔记中看到你写了“字面上的觉醒”，他们的信条是“我们整个社会都在不雅地打鼾，只有诗人和革命者是清醒的”。那正是它，非常19世纪，非常雪莱，本可以写出……绝对，其他人都在睡觉，你知道，他认为应该与奥地利人战斗的所有农民，他们实际上只是，他们根本不在乎这个。他们在照顾他们的鸡。
Yeah, they're looking after, exactly, looking after their chickens. And he's like, they're asleep, but we are awake. I mean, it's that classic thing that teenage idealists and revolutionaries say, isn't it? Now, what he thinks is the neighboring kingdom of Serbia, which is independent, not Austrian, not Ottoman, but its own thing, that should take the lead. It should be the analogy that he uses, that Yugoslav and Serbian nationalists always use in this time, but they talked about the Italian wars of unification, where Piedmont had led the way. Piedmont, Sardinia had led the way in unifying the different bits of Italy. And he says Serbia
是的，他们在照顾，完全正确，照顾他们的鸡。而他就像，他们睡着了，但我们是清醒的。我的意思是，这是青少年理想主义者和革命者所说的经典话语，不是吗？现在，他认为邻国塞尔维亚，它是独立的，不是奥地利的，不是奥斯曼的，而是它自己的东西，那应该带头。它应该是他使用的类比，南斯拉夫和塞尔维亚民族主义者在这一时期总是使用的，但他们谈论的是意大利统一战争，皮埃蒙特带头。皮埃蒙特-撒丁岛在统一意大利的不同部分中带头。他说塞尔维亚
had a moral duty to be the Piedmont of Yugoslavia. And he has been primed for this, I think, because like so many people from his background, he would have grown up with people reciting, singing ballads and poems about medieval Serbia. So the classic example is this ballad or poem about the Battle of Kosovo in 1389, where the Serbs had been smashed by the Ottomans. But afterwards, a Serbian nobleman called Miloš Obilić had assassinated the sultan, the Ottoman sultan. I mean, it's fascinating because, again, this obsession with an ancient battle that kind of lingers in the hearts of an embattled community. Of course, I mean, it reminds me of the role the Battle of the Boyne plays
有道德义务成为南斯拉夫的皮埃蒙特。而且我认为他已经为此做好了准备，因为像他这种背景的许多人一样，他会在人们背诵、演唱关于中世纪塞尔维亚的民谣和诗歌中长大。所以经典的例子是这首关于1389年科索沃战役的民谣或诗歌，塞尔维亚人在那里被奥斯曼人粉碎了。但事后，一位名叫米洛什·奥比利奇的塞尔维亚贵族刺杀了苏丹，奥斯曼苏丹。我的意思是，这很迷人，因为，再次，这种对一场古老战役的痴迷，在饱受战火的社区心中挥之不去。当然，我的意思是，这让我想起了博因河战役所扮演的角色
for Ulster Protestants. But it's incredibly telling. I mean, that's a great victory for Protestantism. Yeah. Whereas this is celebrating a defeat. It is, but that's not uncommon. No, I guess. But two things. I mean, one is that Kosovo at this point is not yet part of Serbia. So that's a problem. But also the date of the Battle of Kosovo is the 28th of June.
对于阿尔斯特新教徒来说。但这非常能说明问题。我的意思是，那是新教的伟大胜利。是的。而这却是在庆祝一场失败。确实，但这并不罕见。不，我想。但有两件事。我的意思是，一是科索沃此时还不是塞尔维亚的一部分。所以那是一个问题。但科索沃战役的日期也是6月28日。
Yes. And that is a date. A really significant date. Obviously will have some resonance in the story that is to come. So Gavrilo Princip has all this stuff in his head. He's read all this stuff about martyrdom, about Serbia, about people fighting empires, all of these things that teenagers actually always read at any point in history. Well, I'm not sure it is actually, not at any point in history. I mean, this is something that's actually quite distinctive, isn't it? Of kind of industrial society that is able to provide mass education.
是的。那是一个日期。一个非常重要的日期。显然在即将到来的故事中会有一些共鸣。所以加夫里洛·普林西普脑子里有所有这些东西。他读过所有关于殉道、关于塞尔维亚、关于人们与帝国战斗的东西，所有这些青少年在历史上的任何时刻实际上总是读的东西。嗯，我不确定它实际上是，不是在历史上的任何时刻。我的意思是，这是实际上相当独特的东西，不是吗？那种能够提供大众教育的工业社会。
Yeah, you're right. Well, I think actually those Serbian epics, they had persisted down the centuries. They'd kind of been passed on around the fire and all that kind of stuff. But that's within peasant communities and villages. But within the cities, you're right. What's different now is that they're deracinated. And so this kind of conversation becomes the new glue
是的，你是对的。嗯，我想实际上那些塞尔维亚史诗，它们在几个世纪中一直存在。它们在火堆旁被传颂，诸如此类。但那是在农民社区和村庄内。但在城市里，你是对的。现在不同的是，它们是无根的。所以这种对话成为了新的粘合剂，
that is sticking together a cadre of impoverished intellectuals. Yeah, I think that's very true. You love an impoverished intellectual, don't you? I actually hate an impoverished intellectual. It's true. So there's the man who is, I think, going to reveal himself very much as Team Franz Ferdinand. Oh, come on. Don't give that away so soon, Tom.
把一群贫困的知识分子粘在一起。是的，我认为那非常真实。你喜欢贫困的知识分子，不是吗？我实际上讨厌贫困的知识分子。这是真的。所以有一个人，我认为他将非常明显地表现为“弗朗茨·斐迪南队”。哦，得了吧。别这么快就泄露出来，汤姆。
I mean, it's actually painful for me to even be doing this story. Listen, talking of impoverished intellectuals, something happens in June 1910 that is massive in this story. And actually, very few people listening to this podcast will probably ever have heard of. So Gavrilo has been here three years. He is what? 16? Could not be at a more impressionable age. And that summer, a guy just like him from Herzegovina, a Bosnian Serb called Bogdan Zerich, fires five shots at the Austro-Hungarian governor of Bosnia, General Marian Varoshanin.
我的意思是，我甚至做这个故事都感到痛苦。听着，说到贫困的知识分子，1910年6月发生了一件在这个故事中非常巨大的事情。而且，实际上，听这个播客的人可能很少有人听说过。所以加夫里洛已经在这里待了三年了。他几岁？16岁？不可能处于更易受影响的年龄了。那个夏天，一个和他一样来自黑塞哥维那的人，一个叫波格丹·热拉伊奇的波斯尼亚塞尔维亚人，向波斯尼亚的奥匈帝国总督、马里安·瓦雷沙宁将军开了五枪。
And the governor, Tom, as you can see just at the end of this alley, the river, the river Miliacka and the quay alongside it, the governor is driving over one of those bridges that we've walked over on that river. Zerich had originally wanted to kill the emperor Franz Josef, but the crowds were very thick when Franz Joseph arrived. People were very excited to see him, so he couldn't do it. So he is standing on what's called the emperor's bridge. The governor drives past.
而总督，汤姆，正如你在这条小巷尽头可以看到的那样，河流，米利亚茨卡河和旁边的码头，总督正开车经过我们走过的那座桥，在那条河上。热拉伊奇最初想杀死皇帝弗朗茨·约瑟夫，但当弗朗茨·约瑟夫到达时，人群非常拥挤。人们非常兴奋地看到他，所以他没能做到。所以他站在所谓的皇帝桥上。总督开车经过。
Zereich shoots five shots. It doesn't say much, actually. He misses with every one, but he doesn't miss with his sixth shot because what he does with his sixth shot he turns the gun on himself and basically blows his own brains out and so suicide is another dimension to the whole i'm a miserable intellectual in a turn of the century dos house isn't it think how much the young man who who takes his own life how that figure has recurred throughout the 19th century young verta all the way so many novels and poems and whatnot life's so unfair exactly exactly yeah zherich takes his
热拉伊奇开了五枪。其实没说什么。他每一枪都打偏了，但他第六枪没有打偏，因为他用第六枪做的是，他把枪对准了自己，基本上把自己的脑浆打出来了。所以自杀是整个“我是世纪之交廉价公寓里的悲惨知识分子”维度的另一个层面，不是吗？想想那个结束自己生命的年轻人，那个形象在整个19世纪是如何反复出现的，年轻的维特，一直到那么多的小说和诗歌等等，生活太不公平了。完全正确，完全正确。是的，热拉伊奇结束了
own life he's lying there on the ground then i have to say the governor behaves quite poorly he does he can behave i mean he behaves like a bulgarian warlord in the 10th century he gets out of his carriage. He walks over to the body. And then there's some sources say he just kicks it. In other words, that he spits on it. So winning hearts and minds there. And then a bloke who works for the police has Zverevich's head cut off
自己的生命，他躺在地上。然后我不得不说，总督的表现相当糟糕。他确实，他可以表现得……我的意思是，他表现得像10世纪的保加利亚军阀。他从马车里走出来。他走到尸体旁。然后有一些消息来源说他只是踢了它。换句话说，他向它吐口水。所以在那儿赢得了民心。然后一个为警察工作的人把热拉伊奇的头砍了下来，
and he uses his skull as an ink pot. Yeah. So that's building bridges with the Serb community there. This is like your ultimate Balkan anecdote, isn't it? So anyway, Gavrilo Princip and his friends, obviously, think this guy, Bogdan Zerich, is the bee's knees. He's brilliant. They think he is absolutely brilliant.
他把他的头骨当作墨水瓶。是的。所以这就是与那里的塞尔维亚社区建立桥梁。这就像你终极的巴尔干轶事，不是吗？所以无论如何，加夫里洛·普林西普和他的朋友们，显然认为这个家伙，波格丹·热拉伊奇，是最好的。他很棒。他们认为他绝对棒极了。
There is a rush of pamphlets and poems. There's one called The Death of a Hero that is very, very famous. If you can have an underground poem that's a bestseller, this is it. All the people who've gone into this say this is an absolutely central text for these guys. And this thing, this Death of a Hero says, Zerich must be a model for all young men.
有一阵传单和诗歌的热潮。有一首叫《英雄之死》的诗非常、非常出名。如果你能有一首地下诗是畅销书，这就是了。所有进入这个领域的人都说这是这些家伙绝对核心的文本。而这首《英雄之死》说，热拉伊奇必须成为所有年轻人的榜样。
Young Serbs, will you produce such men? And for Gavrilo, he said himself at his trial zeriich was my role model at nights i used to go to his grave and i would vow that i would do the same as him i would spend whole nights there and he complained that the grave was neglected and run down he said my friends and i used to go like tart it up with flowers and stuff and pray in front of it well the hapsburg police then said rather sneeringly that they'd nicked them from other graves yes they did but you can absolutely well they haven't got any money right of course yeah you can absolutely believe it it's at this point i think that he drops out of school this is when the grades collapse and where he drops out of
年轻的塞尔维亚人，你们会产生这样的人吗？而对于加夫里洛，他在审判时自己说，热拉伊奇是我的榜样，晚上我常去他的坟墓，我会发誓我会做和他一样的事，我会整晚待在那里。而且他抱怨坟墓被忽视和破败，他说我和我的朋友们常去用花之类的东西装饰它。嗯，哈布斯堡警察后来相当嘲讽地说他们是从其他坟墓偷来的。是的，他们确实这么做了，但你绝对可以……嗯，他们没有钱，对吧？当然。是的，你绝对可以相信。我认为就在这一点上，他辍学了，这是成绩崩溃的时候，也是他辍学的时候，
school and he drifts for a year or so and then it it's in early 1912, so what is he now? He's 17, that he decides, you know what, there's nothing for me here in Sarajevo. I'm actually going to go to Belgrade in Serbia. I know. It's okay. No, sorry. I'm not giving you the microphone. So what does now happen, ladies and gentlemen? It's that the old Balkan hand is swapping anecdotes. Right, so Serbia, it had been a part of the Ottoman Empire for centuries and centuries following the great defeat at Kosovo.
学校，他漂泊了一年左右，然后是在1912年初，所以他现在几岁？他17岁，他决定，你知道吗，我在萨拉热窝这里什么都没有。我实际上要去塞尔维亚的贝尔格莱德。我知道。没关系。不，抱歉。我不会把麦克风给你。那么现在发生了什么，女士们先生们？是那位老巴尔干手在交换轶事。对，所以塞尔维亚，它在科索沃大败后，几个世纪以来一直是奥斯曼帝国的一部分。
But it's been independent of the Ottomans since 1878. It's quite small, isn't it? There are only kind of two million. And it's quite economically backward. So, I mean, it's much poorer, say, than Bosnia. Yeah, so certainly in the rural hinterland of Serbia, it's poorer than much of Bosnia is. And part of that is because Serbia, as you said, two million people, Orthodox. Serbia had been tied into the Ottoman economic system.
但自1878年以来，它就脱离了奥斯曼帝国独立了。它很小，不是吗？只有大约两百万人。而且它在经济上相当落后。所以，我的意思是，它比波斯尼亚穷得多。是的，当然在塞尔维亚的农村腹地，它比波斯尼亚的大部分地区要穷。而部分原因是塞尔维亚，正如你所说，两百万人，东正教。塞尔维亚一直被束缚在奥斯曼经济体系中。
And when it was cut off from the Ottoman economic system, there's kind of nowhere to go. The largely Muslim land-earning elites have left, by and large. Which is unlike Bosnia. Yeah. The cities have actually declined. So someone like Belgrade has actually declined in population under independence. And they've had a spectacular murder of their king, haven't they? Yeah.
当它被切断与奥斯曼经济体系的联系时，基本上无处可去。主要是穆斯林土地所有精英已经离开，大体上是这样。这与波斯尼亚不同。是的。城市实际上已经衰落了。所以像贝尔格莱德这样的人在独立下人口实际上已经减少了。而且他们经历了一场壮观的国王谋杀案，不是吗？是的。
So we mentioned how the king of Serbia had been murdered in 1903. And his queen. Queen Draga. Queen Draga, who... She's a character. Tremendous character. So the king, who I think was about 10 years younger than her, murdered in 1903 and his queen queen draga queen draga who um character tremendous character so the the king who i think was about 10 years younger than her had announced to his cabinet that he wanted to marry her and the interior minister said sir you cannot marry her she has been everybody's mistress mine included but the king didn't worry about that married her yeah they were terrible yeah and they both got killed they all get killed after hiding in a cupboard for two hours.
所以我们提到了塞尔维亚国王是如何在1903年被谋杀的。还有他的王后。德拉加王后。德拉加王后，她……她是一个人物。了不起的人物。所以国王，我想他比她小10岁左右，在1903年被谋杀，还有他的王后，德拉加王后，德拉加王后，她……人物，了不起的人物。所以国王，我想他比她小10岁左右，曾向他的内阁宣布他想娶她，内政部长说，陛下，你不能娶她，她曾是所有人的情妇，包括我在内。但国王并不担心这一点，娶了她。是的，他们很糟糕。是的，他们都被杀了。他们在躲在橱柜里两个小时后都被杀了。
It's a terrible story. So Serbia has a very, very troubled political culture. So first of all, it has a sense of an obsession with martyrdom and sacrifice that goes back to the Battle of Kosovo. It also has a sense of frustration and sort of betrayal that is partly actually because since independence, it hasn't done very well economically. So people are actually poorer rather than better off in 1903 as you say the last monarch of the obrenovich
这是一个可怕的故事。所以塞尔维亚有一种非常、非常麻烦的政治文化。所以首先，它有一种对殉道和牺牲的痴迷感，可以追溯到科索沃战役。它还有一种挫败感和某种背叛感，部分原因实际上是因为自独立以来，它在经济上并没有做得很好。所以人们实际上比1903年更穷，而不是更好，正如你所说，奥布雷诺维奇王朝的最后一位君主
dynasty king alexander and his wife kundraga they hide in the cupboard they are absolutely horrendously mutilated and and murdered quite kind of uh lakota very treatment of their bodies of their bodies yeah horrifically mutilated one of of the regicides, a man called Vemic, who was an officer, army officer. He's an army officer, done it. He walked around for years, Tom, with a piece of the queen's breast in a suitcase. Wow.
亚历山大国王和他的妻子德拉加，他们躲在橱柜里，他们遭到了极其残忍的肢解和谋杀，对他们的遗体进行了非常……呃，拉科塔式的处理，是的，被极其残忍地肢解了。其中一名弑君者，一个叫维米奇的人，他是一名军官，陆军军官。他是一名陆军军官，干了这事。汤姆，他带着王后乳房的一块碎片在手提箱里走了好几年。哇。
Which is very peculiar behavior. Yeah, very. Now, all of this matters because it has a long afterlife in Serbian politics. So the regicides, the conspirators who'd murdered the king and queen, they become great heroes for the people because the king and queen were seen as too pro-austrian and they play an outsized part in serbian public life afterwards in kind of nationalist politics in paramilitary groups and
这是一种非常奇特的行为。是的，非常奇特。现在，所有这些都很重要，因为它在塞尔维亚政治中有着深远的影响。所以那些弑君者，那些谋杀国王和王后的阴谋家，他们成了人民心目中的大英雄，因为国王和王后被认为太亲奥地利了，此后他们在塞尔维亚的公共生活中，在某种民族主义政治和准军事组织中，扮演了极其重要的角色，
so on and the most famous of these a man i know that you're very interested in uh do you want to tell us his name tom of course in serbian it's dragotin dimitrijevic dimitrijevic yeah but it's much more sensibly called apis after the apis bull of egypt of egypt mentioned by herodotus um and the reason for that is basically he looks like a bull yes i mean he's a huge great bloke yeah i think it's fair to say that if he were alive today in serbia he'd be a great enthusiast for one of those kind of faded combat caps that serbian hard men love to wear i can picture him surrounded by his coterie at some enormous outdoor barbecue yeah but in combat fatigue in combat fatigues with balkan turbo folk playing very loudly on
等等。其中最著名的一位，我知道你对他很感兴趣，呃，你想告诉我们他的名字吗，汤姆？当然，在塞尔维亚语中是德拉古廷·迪米特里耶维奇，迪米特里耶维奇，是的，但人们更习惯称他为“阿皮斯”，取自希罗多德提到的埃及阿皮斯公牛，呃，原因基本上是他长得像头公牛。是的，我的意思是，他是个大块头。是的，我认为可以公平地说，如果他今天还活在塞尔维亚，他会非常热衷于那种塞尔维亚硬汉喜欢戴的褪色战斗帽。我可以想象他被一群亲信簇拥在某个巨大的户外烧烤派对上，是的，穿着战斗服，巴尔干涡轮民歌在扬声器里大声播放，
the loudspeakers and people talking darkly of attacking kosovo yes that's his scene that's very much his vibe so Apis becomes a national hero because of his role in the conspiracy, killing the king and queen. He loves plotting. He loves code names. He loves rituals. And as we will see,
人们阴沉地谈论着攻击科索沃。是的，这就是他的场景，这非常符合他的氛围。所以阿皮斯因为他在阴谋中杀害国王和王后的角色而成为了民族英雄。他喜欢策划。他喜欢代号。他喜欢仪式。正如我们将要看到的，
he has a massive part to play in this story that leads us to the outbreak of the First World War. So as all this suggests, by far the biggest political force in Serbia is ethnic nationalism. The Serbian mission, as they see it, is unfinished. It's barely started. What they want to do is they build a greater Serbia, taking what's now Albania, Kosovo, what is now North Macedonia, even down as far as Greece. Yeah, because if you are the ruler of a non-Serbian country with Serbs in it,
他在导致第一次世界大战爆发的这个故事中扮演了极其重要的角色。正如所有这些所暗示的，塞尔维亚最大的政治力量无疑是民族主义。在他们看来，塞尔维亚的使命尚未完成。它才刚刚开始。他们想要做的是建立一个大塞尔维亚，吞并现在的阿尔巴尼亚、科索沃、现在的北马其顿，甚至远至希腊。是的，因为如果你是一个有塞尔维亚人居住的非塞尔维亚国家的统治者，
they have a rather menacing catchphrase, which is, where a Serb dwells, that is Serbia. Exactly. Now, to be fair to them, that is not uncommon among nationalists across Europe. But in Serbia, it is probably more than anywhere else mixed with this kind of paramilitary politics. So, of course, when the Austrians annexed Bosnia-Herzegovina in 1908, that was a massive shock to the Serbian sort of paramilitary nationalist
他们有一句相当具有威胁性的口号，那就是：有塞尔维亚人居住的地方，就是塞尔维亚。没错。现在，公平地说，这在欧洲各地的民族主义者中并不罕见。但在塞尔维亚，它可能比其他任何地方都更多地与这种准军事政治混合在一起。所以，当然，当奥地利人在1908年吞并波斯尼亚-黑塞哥维那时，这对塞尔维亚的准军事民族主义运动来说是一个巨大的冲击，
movement. It really ratchets them up, makes them absolutely furious. They despise the Austrians because of this. So when Gavrilo Princip arrives in Belgrade in 1912, Belgrade is full of people like him. People who hate the Austrians, people who dream of a greater Slav state with Serbia in the vanguard as the Prussia or the Piedmont of this state. So he arrives and he thinks, brilliant, Belgrade is going to be the promised land. Actually, he goes back to school.
这真的激怒了他们，让他们变得极其愤怒。他们因此鄙视奥地利人。所以当加夫里洛·普林西普在1912年到达贝尔格莱德时，贝尔格莱德到处都是像他这样的人。那些憎恨奥地利人的人，那些梦想着建立一个以塞尔维亚为先锋，作为这个国家的普鲁士或皮埃蒙特的伟大斯拉夫国家的人。所以他到了那里，心想，太棒了，贝尔格莱德将是应许之地。实际上，他回去上学了。
He goes to the high school, the gymnasium in Belgrade, but he fails his exams he's distracted tom by revolutionary politics revolutionary politics by mooning around at people's graves and stuff yeah so then another blow i think to his sense of self-esteem in october 1912 so he's been there what nine months six months the first balkan war begins so what happens here is Serbia teams up with Bulgaria, Greece, Montenegro, all of them Orthodox countries to take on the Ottomans. So basically bite off loads of Ottoman territory and they win crushing victories for Serbian men. This is an incredibly
他去了贝尔格莱德的高中，也就是文理中学，但他考试不及格。汤姆，他被革命政治分心了，被革命政治分心了，整天在别人的坟墓前徘徊之类的。是的，所以这对他的自尊心又是一个打击，我想是在1912年10月，所以他在那里待了大概九个月，六个月，第一次巴尔干战争开始了。所以这里发生的事情是，塞尔维亚与保加利亚、希腊、黑山联手，所有这些东正教国家一起对抗奥斯曼帝国。所以基本上是咬下大量的奥斯曼领土，他们取得了决定性的胜利。对于塞尔维亚男人来说，这是一个极其
exciting and glorious moment. Well, I mean, it leaves Serbia a much more menacing figure, doesn't it? A kind of regional big power. Yes, yes it does but gavrilo princip is not part of them because he applied did some of the basic training and then he was turned down for being too much of a weed yeah well i mean even lee harvey oswald got into the army yeah he's seen as too sickly wanted to go into the balkan war but was found too weak his austrian psychiatrist wrote in his notes after his trial so for gavrilo princip this is an absolutely devastating moment and for the next couple of years he's just hanging around in belgrade and kind of dos houses and cafes with other bosnian exiles so these cafes all have very sort of romantic sounding names.
令人兴奋和光荣的时刻。嗯，我的意思是，这让塞尔维亚成了一个更具威胁性的人物，不是吗？一种区域性的大国。是的，确实如此，但加夫里洛·普林西普不是他们的一员，因为他申请参加了一些基础训练，然后因为太瘦弱而被拒绝了。是的，嗯，我的意思是，连李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德都参军了。是的，他被认为太虚弱了，想参加巴尔干战争，但被发现太虚弱了。他的奥地利精神科医生在审判后的笔记中写道，所以对于加夫里洛·普林西普来说，这是一个绝对毁灭性的时刻，在接下来的几年里，他只是在贝尔格莱德的廉价旅馆和咖啡馆里和其他波斯尼亚流亡者混在一起。所以这些咖啡馆都有非常浪漫的名字。
They're called like the Acorn Garland, the Little Goldfish and so on. And it's full of these basically boys, young men, nursing a coffee for hours because they haven't got much money. You're boasting about the great atrocities they will one day carry out
它们的名字像“橡子花环”、“小金鱼”等等。这里面基本上全是这些男孩，年轻人，花几个小时喝一杯咖啡，因为他们没有多少钱。你吹嘘着他们有一天会犯下的伟大暴行，
against the Austrian bullies who've always been horrible to them. So if they're around today, they would all be on dark web. They would be. Chat rooms. They would absolutely be. Kind of plotting atrocities and things.
针对那些一直对他们很糟糕的奥地利恶霸。所以如果他们今天还在，他们都会在暗网上。他们会的。聊天室。他们绝对会。那种策划暴行之类的事情。
They totally would be. And Gavrilo is right there in the thick of it. They all know him. And he is by now a very bitter and disaffected young man. He says later, wherever I went, people took me for a weakling. Indeed, for a man who had been completely ruined by the moderate study of literature. And I pretended that I was a weak person, even though I was not.
他们绝对会。而加夫里洛就深陷其中。他们都认识他。而他现在是一个非常痛苦和不满的年轻人。他后来写道，无论我走到哪里，人们都把我当作一个弱者。确实，对于一个被温和的文学研究完全毁掉的人来说。我假装自己是一个软弱的人，尽管我并不是。
So there's this kind of self-loathing there, clearly. So therefore, presumably, he wants to prove that he's not weak. He wants to take a step that will echo around the world. Yes, exactly. He wants to prove he's a man, I think. He wants to prove he's not weak. He wants to take a step that will echo around the world. Yes, exactly. He wants to prove he's a man, I think. He wants to prove he's a man. And so, Dominic, I mean, what a cliffhanger. What's going to happen? How is he going to prove himself? Will he be able to take an action that everyone will hear about and mean that people will be recording podcasts about him 110 years after he takes this incredible step. Only one way to find out, and that is to tune into our next episode, which will be coming very soon.
所以这显然有一种自我厌恶。因此，大概他想证明自己并不软弱。他想迈出一步，在全世界引起回响。是的，没错。我想他想证明自己是个男人。他想证明自己并不软弱。他想迈出一步，在全世界引起回响。是的，没错。我想他想证明自己是个男人。他想证明自己是个男人。所以，多米尼克，我的意思是，真是个悬念。会发生什么？他将如何证明自己？他能采取一个让全世界都能听到，并意味着人们在他采取这一不可思议的步骤110年后还在为他录制播客的行动吗？只有一个办法可以知道，那就是收听我们的下一集，很快就会播出。
But if you want to hear it immediately, you can, of course, go to therestishistory.com, where we have three more episodes, don't we, specifically on the story of Princip and the assassination. And then after that, we will be looking at the broader road to the outbreak of the First World War. It's an incredible story. I hope you've enjoyed this and I hope you'll be joining us for the rest of the episodes. But for now, bye-bye. Dovahzhenia. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host
但如果你想立即收听，你当然可以去therestishistory.com，我们在那里还有三集，不是吗，专门讲述普林西普和暗杀的故事。在那之后，我们将着眼于通往第一次世界大战爆发的更广泛的道路。这是一个不可思议的故事。我希望你喜欢这个节目，也希望你能加入我们收听剩下的剧集。但现在，再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持
The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment
《剩下的就是娱乐》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐界的帷幕，
and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。